to
[Music]
what is uh
people of the universe
it's july 25th
and today's episode episode is sponsored
by hellofresh thank you so much
welcome everybody
to the number 12 episode in the world
and all known life
number 12
number 12 what you said number 12
episode number 12 podcast bro when's my
brain gonna start working dude no
yup yup is my brain does my brain work
no
do i wish it did
yeah
thank you that's e40 everybody
yeah
yeah
that's actually a callback to the member
stream we did on saturday which was a
lot of fun thank you everybody who
joined us it was a little bit of a
fiasco
we we tried watching tippy toes uh our
stream got taken down and then we ended
up
doing karaoke and then playing jack box
it was a kind of a disaster but i guess
i guess some people had fun yeah people
loved it reddit and the comments seemed
to really like it
looks like tiptoe's gonna work out but
yeah dude
it's kind of effed up because like
youtube's for some reason makes a they
see that we're like streaming a video
and they make this pre
conceived decision that that we the
stream must be taken down it's like
hello this is biting social criticism
it is dan why are you laughing
what the [ __ ] are you laughing damn uh
yeah no you're right thank you yeah
yeah it's fair use and but anyway so we
couldn't do it
and uh
but anyway it was fun so thank everyone
who joined and followed us watched
enjoyed
wow
how was you guys this weekend besides
that
uh it was good i went out to eat out
with dan for his birthday him and ally
and me lena it's fun are you guys having
audio issues again dan or is everything
fine
uh
maybe
we're having a slight issue yeah what's
the what's the deal
um
one of the channels is louder than the
other
oh we got challenge ch channel issues
well that's got to be better than the
last weeks right
so you guys went out to uh
is it unlistenable should i wait or
no it's fine okay
you guys you guys all went out to eat
together yeah that's pretty dope yeah it
was a nice time where did you guys go
somewhere nice uh
i think i forget the name of the
restaurant is a mexican restaurant but
yeah it's really good
good times good vibes good people nice
um
huge news coming out of the week and
big news
sam and e and we celebrated their
ninja cosplay
and you guys were angling to get some
free g fuel i mean that that ultimately
you were trying to get recognized by
daddy
ninja
and blevins jessica blevins i mean you
know
we were doing it for the love of of the
game as i've said before i am a member
of the blevins brotherhood and sam yes
too so
yeah
obviously it'd be a nice
nice to get some recognition from
from papa
and uh yeah here's the video to refresh
you guys's memory
oh wait no we didn't show this we saw
that you guys dressed up but check this
out you guys made it on the news now
wait for this
wait for this
wait for this
who is it ian
sam and your buddy right yep
love the commitment
yeah that's uh that's our buddy drew so
three ninjas right by the way so short
now let me ask you this how long did
they film you for because that was like
a half second
it wasn't that long it was like maybe 10
seconds
okay it was just a little stinger shot
it was like right right when they got
there they came up and they're like hey
can we film you for what was it cbs or
something pbs8 yeah did you guys did you
guys have to fill out a consent form no
did they did you say on camera that you
consent
yup yup
no you did what's he asked she asked
beforehand okay all right is there any
proof of it
um is it on the record
that's what i'm saying because i'm just
saying time to lawyer the [ __ ] up dude
never
just saying
any anyone helping to get the word out
of the you know the
nina gospel i'm on board you're like the
12 you're like one of the first 12 wise
men in yeah
yep yup
ever told on a ninja nope
ever pull the trigger yup
um taking double using fortnite yup yup
just like nina
so that's pretty exciting but wait it
gets even better you guys
it gets even better if you can imagine a
world
dude that looks like ninja bro i thought
that was ninja at first
thank you this is ian dropping truth
bombs on instagram
by the way in the
uh 2020 winner of getting an email to
instagram
thank you
thank you thank you looks like you guys
actually had fun comic-con is that where
you guys were yes was it a good time it
was a lot of fun it was so fun i'd never
been so i was having a blast
people say that people like stink there
did you find that to be true or no
was there smells
i didn't really smell anyone yeah that
seems like racially motivated against
nerds it was also a mask it was mask
required so i okay and if people did
stink i probably would not have smelled
it really okay it's probably cause all
the costumes you know like i'm sure
sonic stunk
the shirt this picture's fire
but yeah what up what a bunch of
goofsters that is eh
and then but wait it gets even better my
friends yes the
ninja and jessica you dude they
recognize you guys check this out on
twitter
now dan retweeted this from the podcast
and i don't know if that [ __ ] it up i
was gonna like it but we discussed
backstage
we decided i would not like this tweet
because i don't want to [ __ ] it up for
you guys
so if they end up ghosting you it's
dan's fault
i'll be so bummed out
you know if if they rescind the offer
here
well let's check it out i hope they
don't i mean this is real fan friend
dumb here you can i i have never said
anything bad against nina neither has
sam yeah my my views do you guys my
views do not represent you guys you guys
are independent thinkers
by the way i love ninja i just said once
that he looks like middle aged woman and
like so what i mean it happens sometimes
i look like the [ __ ] michelin man so
what
but anyway you guys tweeted at jessica
blevins his wife and manager we went to
comic-con as ninja can we have some
g-fuel
is this copyrighted music probably yep
but that's his dance
that's oh they actually put that in
fortnight yeah
isn't that the one he did on the
disastrous new year's eve that was the
floss oh
how is this a dance i just i mean i i
don't want to i don't want to be a hater
together bro
i i don't want to be a hater right out
the gate but like
how is that a dance
all right fair enough i'm just i'm just
one man's opinion but here's where it
gets magical
ninja bro leaves a comment
hell no any tags g fuel bro
what's happening then click on his tweet
and
i believe
and then wait and then his wife and
manager jessica
this is amazing we're gonna get you all
hooked up dude
number one victory mission accomplished
battle royale victory so i hope me
talking about it doesn't [ __ ] it up
because this is this has nothing to do
with me yes this is about sam and ian's
love for the game and nothing else do
not the sins of the father do not carry
on no we've we know that
yeah
yeah this was a chug chug moment for
sure
jug jug yeah yeah definitely what is
that
it's uh
oh my god ethan i don't play fortnite i
don't know what that is
yeah it gives you shield
okay good moment good you know what was
so funny though is like
kids were going nuts
kids love ninja
like yeah who the [ __ ] else did you
think was watching that [ __ ] well it's
so funny everyone in this office man
i'm just kidding we love you ninjas like
kids would see us and they would go like
ninja
like we were like mickey mouse at
disneyland dude that's did you take any
photos with people
uh a couple people came up a few what
was funny was then like older people
would come up and be like kind of like
sarcastic they would like yo are you
tyler ninja fortnite blevins they all
said that
um that's a mouthful yeah they're just
like you know goofing on us but
uh no this one kid it was so funny we
the moment we got there this kid walked
by
and his eyes like widened and he like
just started flossing like
like you just must have lost in the
presence of ninja yeah he's like the
pied piper
yeah he's just floss and follow his ass
where he goes he's habitual he's just
playing a little tune
actually cameron's been blessed by ninja
too this is breaking news actually
check it out
cam grants oh cam how long you've been
sitting on this clip bro
a bit
we're we're all paying subscribers to
ninjas yeah that's how you know we're
doing it if i'm not mistaken didn't he
shout out love in this same stream
well love paid like five other i'm his
buddy
you guys are homies
yeah love you didn't get noticed at
first so you had to pay like you to get
like
so wait where's your shout out you
haven't thought of it
uh yeah somewhere well what the [ __ ]
don't hold down on me let me see it ah
[ __ ] but it's not my real name you know
it's young feet
we know who you are
i'll i'll look for it all right well
here's cameron's let's let's not take
away from cameron's big moment yeah
damn grand second sir what's up dude
[Music]
wow man that was
you know we need a sound bite of that oh
that was crazy it still makes my heart
look better
zach we need a sound bite of that you
got it uh anytime we just want to
congratulate cam i think we got to pull
that out you got it let me hear that
again damn grand sequencer what's up
dude
right literally
it's almost inaudible dude
thank you for what's up dad
he's so good at doing that just getting
him out damn grandson sir what's up dude
what does he say
thanks for the tier one sub dude i think
what's the cheer i'm not fluent in ninja
so i'm not entirely sure that's a little
bit less of a
many others in this office but that was
my interpretation
is tier one a good sub or better than
tier three or that's not the good one
it's
i don't want to out anybody but it's the
cheap one
yes so is he is he calling you out kind
of cam
[Laughter]
you're welcome dude thank you for
showing me that's about anyway
congratulations to all you who have been
touched by an angel pissed by an angel
what if god was one of us
ninja would be
ninja is god he is one of us his name is
ninja you sent it to me
yeah oh [ __ ] here comes loves
wow this is huge um
i cannot believe how many times our our
paths have crossed
let's do it
young figure thank you for the three
gift of rob
[Laughter]
[Applause]
can i suggest that we keep getting ninja
sound bites i'm thinking
all the crew
i'll try to work them tonight can you
guys can you guys try to get one for
ethan olivia and sam and ian and
everybody just prove it we're dedicated
to them yeah we're paying them
we love them
wait here it comes again
young figure thank you for the three
gift of bro
three gifts it's incredible how he does
it like in one syllable almost
young people thank you very much oh my
god
there you go man this is exciting
i told you a lot of excitement happened
over the weekend
but y'all didn't want to believe me
you got that one zack yep
are you gonna forget that one zack no
did you have a good weekend zach
did you [ __ ] on someone's grass
yep okay that one was supposed to be no
like i meant over the weekend
it's a maybe it's a maybe
yeah so um there you have it
oh i want to show you guys something fun
too
i know you guys are probably sick of
seeing teddy fresh stuff but never
this is coming out this week
on thursday
do we ever show these on the show i
don't think so i've been wanting to show
these for so long so i took a shot bro i
just went out on a limb now i these are
my concepts but obviously that
incredible art was mass remastered by a
i'll tell you what it's not easy
to get
shitty looking art that looks good this
is talent and i you think i'm joking
there's a very talented artist that
interpreted
my genius
now i wanted to do even more of these i
had other people in mind
but we said let's start with these guys
and see if anyone's gonna buy this [ __ ]
but it seems there's some excitement
elon musk is a piece of [ __ ] loser
and jeff bezos of course has a small
penis as proof
by his phallic rocket hell yes
kind of fire
i'm glad people seem to like it yeah
chat is loving it okay good i was not
sure but i would because i was like i
don't know if someone i would wear the
[ __ ] out of these shirts bro
i'm thinking i want to make a ben
shapiro shirt nest that's that's funny
because i'm so tired of that little
[ __ ] gremlin hateful gremlin [ __ ] is
he like
would people know who he was yeah he
made a shirt unfortunately oh yeah i
mean obviously he doesn't have the
status of jeff bezos and elon musk
that's like the ultimate
so
yeah he has a following my cousins are
muslims they like him and he hates
muslims
wow yeah yeah interesting how that works
yep
yeah bench appear but anyway cool i'm
glad you guys like that i mean there's
other stuff too but
let's be honest who gives a [ __ ]
i don't mean it like that sorry no
everyone cares but i the joke was that
you know
these are okay good i'm glad you guys
like it so yeah
this thursday get your hands on jeff
bezos [ __ ]
chet's saying jordan peterson i would
love to but again my fear is you have to
go for like
you can't go too niche with this
other people i was thinking the target
is like bill gates
would be so funny classic like drinking
[ __ ] water or something or hanging out
with jeffrey epstein epstein is my best
buddy
you know that'd be [ __ ] awesome
or it could be like bill gates or i
don't know if people want epstein on a
shirt though that's a little tricky
you have bill gates with a bracelet on
it that says epstein like a friendship
bracelet
that's a good detail just a subtle
little detail like that we were
discussing putting harvey weinstein on
that
on the merch before not teddy fresh but
on h3 merch yeah unfortunately people i
think we learned that people don't want
to wear a shirt with harvey weinstein's
face on it even if it is a
meme i mean him nope it's kind of hard
to explain
it's my boy harvey
great [ __ ] movies man
but okay that's fun so so this is a fun
new project for me i'm glad you guys
liked it
ela took a shot at me she believed in me
everyone was like dude this is a little
nuts
but the thing that really pulled
together i think is the art the way they
interpreted the art i think
it's perfect how it's like childish but
you can still tell who it is
uh it's irreverent
uh
i think it's awesome
love it
glad you guys liked it
it's exciting
i'm an artist at the end of the day am i
not i can't help but express myself
just kidding
uh well um
listen
lots of good stuff happening
oh by the way the reason i was thinking
of doing um ben shapiro
this hateful little i'm so sick
of this [ __ ]
little
[ __ ] i want to
punt his ass like a goddamn football
uh and you could he's that small
this dude
is such a piece of [ __ ]
he goes
it goes on with this this i think this
guy's a senator ted right from
california
we love ted shut up ted lowell or
whatever the [ __ ]
uh ben shapiro goes the beauty of
marriage according to our esteemed media
all forms of human pairing are more
morally equivalent and similarly
societally useful we must maintain that
this lie is so in order to facilitate
sexual self-esteem bro you are doing
like deep deep
religious pr hate propaganda like the
fact that he's even conf this is like
the number one conservative
talk media person the fact that he's
even comfortable tweeting something that
bigoted and hateful is incredible to me
because we're all pretending that all
forms of human parallel
pairing are morally equivalent what the
[ __ ] does morals have to do with human
pairings [ __ ]
what does a straight couple more moral
than a gay couple i don't even
understand because they're able to
reproduce
like that's i guess at least the [ __ ]
i'd be happy if you reproduced less and
they had more kids adopted i'd be happy
if they adopted your kids
give them to them
we must maintain this lie
in order to facilitate sexual
self-esteem well that's one that's where
it starts
our society has deemed it a mystery
wrapped in an enigma why western
civilization promoted
heterosexual monogamy into the last 30
seconds which everybody in the world did
that that's like saying well all that we
all all of a sudden until 30 seconds ago
we just freed all of our slaves
the whole world was down with slavery
what happened
it is not a mystery but again we must
pretend
that the obvious
is mysterious in order to achieve a
societal transformation so what is the
mystery then
i just don't understand there's always
some kind of like
paranoia about why everybody's in on
this lie to tell me that gay marriage
is fine
everybody's in on this lie
what is the lie
what is the mystery
do you know damn i'm like serious what
what is it that he thinks
is the conspiracy
uh it's uh obviously a uh postmodern
um
uh
frankfurt school inspired uh neo-marxist
uh something bolshevik uh i know you're
kidding but i just really don't
understand it i i
what's the conspiracy and then ted lauer
to what end to what end is the
conspiracy well they say they say we're
all in on this mystery this lie
we're supposed to pretend what's not
going on what's we're supposed to
pretend like we don't know what's
happening the whole premise the way that
he frames it is just nonsensical
why do we pretend that it's a mystery
that until recently
uh you know gay marriage wasn't allowed
i mean it's not a mystery we know why
it's because it cultural norms
you know
religious
uh dominance of
culture
that's i mean there's lots of it's not a
mystery like you can point to a lot of
reasons i but like you said i mean just
because something used to be
morally acceptable and is you know
doesn't mean it still should be now
there is like this weird conspiracy that
actually doesn't make any sense to me
but apparently people believe it that
there is some deep
conspiracy to turn people gay to
undermine traditional families
to destroy society i just it's like
who's who's doing that about is that
like who's the batman villain uh we live
in the united states
trying to get gay people married
he's just like bro what are you talking
about you're paranoid
anyway ted says why does bench bureau
hate americans who happen to be lgbtq
why does he believe only certain people
have the right to love and be loved
that's a great question ted
ben responds to him there is no
constitutional right for two men or two
women to marry one another the founders
would have died laughing
there is no moral right to government
approval
for whatever sexual relationship you
form that doesn't mean a legal bar
to such activity i mean first of all
wait there is it's the 14th amendment
there's i feel like there's several
different ways you can literally say
that gay marriage is enshrined in the
constitution right all people are are
equal the government should not infrin
or should not impose religion on
on people i mean this this all comes
from a religious so it's like
this is infringing on so many rights in
my opinion
and by the way
one thing that i'm just [ __ ] tired of
seeing
is
us treating the founding fathers like
some moral north star
these are people that own slaves i mean
what else do you want to say they're not
exactly
they're they've not exactly
stood up
to every moral development we've had in
humanity they're not moral north stars
and i'm not one of these people that
like hates the founding fathers
i for for the most part i think they're
all pretty incredible dudes and i don't
think it's fair to judge people
for what they felt during a time
during the world when it was a norm you
know i think it's it's when there's
exceptional people that can see like yo
we shouldn't have slaves that's
exceptional but to like you know try to
write off someone like george washington
because he had slaves to me seems a
little unfair to him
but
but at the same time
to put every word they have as gospel is
[ __ ] insane i'm so
sick
of people being like the founding
fathers would have laughed [ __ ] they
owned slaves
they would have laughed at the idea of
[ __ ] black people drinking from this
being able to ride a bus you idiot bro
you [ __ ] more had their minds blown
by the concept of a bus yeah do you know
what a bus is benchmare you [ __ ] i
wonder what the founding fathers thought
about jews by the way benny boy
was there any jews in the constitutional
convention
uh
doubtful
i don't know that a hundred percent but
google it that's easy to find out
well e40 said no founding father uh no
at the time
[Music]
i don't think they were able to serve in
state legislature zero jews bro they
would have laughed you dumb [ __ ]
you stupid [ __ ]
you come from a marginalized group and
here you are how closed mind can you be
the founding fathers would have died
laughing [ __ ] they would have died
laughing at the thought of you even
serving in the constitutional convention
so why are you holding them to be the
north star of morality
you can even hold any public office you
goofy little [ __ ]
you just hate gay people just say it
just get it out there ben
just say inside your walls yeah dude
just say you hate gay people just get it
out
you know
i'm so sick of seeing this little
gremlin dude i i quote to him i said who
gives a [ __ ] what dead slave owners
thought about gay marriage you hate gay
people just say it
so tired of like open homophobia and
transphobia like violent [ __ ]
rhetoric i feel like it wasn't like this
like it's
resurging it wasn't like this you know
when obama was president shout out to a
real one
dan you hate obama don't you
i i don't hate obama shout out to a real
one
necessarily a big fan of obama's but
why because he was killing people with
drones
yeah that and
the fact that he
you know
bailed out all the banks that crashed
the economy and
uh
a few other things yeah but did you see
him dance on ellen yeah that was tight
okay
yo i don't give a [ __ ] but like i don't
know what happened but since trump the
trump uh presidency
basically
it's the amount of open homophobia like
violent hateful reddit rhetoric betw
towards them and trans people is a
[ __ ] disgrace dude to this country as
a dark [ __ ] time for human rights
right now oh and don't even get me
started on uh reproductive rights
it's so funny that he thinks he's right
and like you know in 50 years he's going
to be he's a villain i mean he's a
villain he will be forgotten he will not
be respected he will be known if known
at all as a [ __ ] villain
with a bad book
bad
book what's his book didn't he write a
really bad book about himself
i'm sure i think this guy's like these
write a ton of books uh ben shapiro has
written several books i believe they're
usually fiction kind of pseudo uh judy
right like a superhero yeah
i'm not super familiar but i've heard
that like threat level midnight type
stuff
like military bootlicking fanfic
um
have you ever seen this clip of obama
let me see it
yeah another guy said but i tell you
what you won't see me moving to no
african jungle anytime soon
or some goddamn desert somewhere sitting
on a carpet
with a bunch of air abs no sir
and you you won't see me stop eating no
ribs either
you gotta have them ribs
and [ __ ] too
okay but he's reading something no i
know it's just
a [ __ ] too
i ain't never gonna stop eating [ __ ]
amed president we need that as a sound
bite anytime we mention that's my
president
and [ __ ] too
[Laughter]
shout out to a real one
you know
so i'm just sitting here and it's like
i don't know bro we you can't it's like
dude you're way too comfortable right
now tweeting this kind of [ __ ] like
openly saying that you're way too
comfortable bro
yo don't unders how dare you even talk
about the founding fathers [ __ ]
whatever happens separation church and
state and the right to you
to practice any religion or non-religion
that you want
you goofy
you goofy little [ __ ] troll with the
jewel in your heart
but a pit number one pit in your heart a
jewel in your tummy but a bit in your
heart you know the trolls never
mind tough one this is hard to land that
one
oh god he's such a [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
yep
so i don't maybe i'll make a bench hero
shirt
certainly hate him enough
but uh so there's that and then
obviously you know i was talking a lot
of smack on chiropractors last week
and you know i think i need to apologize
to the chiropractors you know i saw
something that really
[Music]
i saw something that that kind of proved
me wrong
and um
well i'll just play for you guys and and
i think it speaks for itself so
with apologies to all chiropractors
i present this
what and i says i present this you will
not believe what i just found in my
chiropractic textbook this is an
adjustment where you stick your finger
in the patient's butt
the idea is to adjust the coccyx bone
right here
no i've never done it
that's what the [ __ ] is up bro that's in
chiropractic textbooks do you could put
two fingers in the ass so you can adjust
god knows what stick your finger
you mean you're just fingering someone's
[ __ ] hunger
adjusting yeah i'm adjusting yeah so is
it also a prostate exam too or yeah it's
kind of good for that way yeah
get milked get an exam get adjusted
what is this a turd by the way what are
you fingering his turd fondling his
little
nugs
yeah quack science sorry
someone says the crew needs to test this
one out anyone volunteer
yo i wonder if there i wonder if we
could find a chiropractor who specialize
in this though probably right
yeah and then have people would anyone
be down to try that how about you
well you are 40 you're due for a
prostate yeah i'm saying no
50
first of all i'm not 40. thanks for
when do
i need a prostate exam i think it's 50.
it's never too soon to start it says uh
let's see men
show their first prostate exam by age
50. well they say by age 50. right 45 to
50. if you have prostate cancer in your
family 45 i don't have that
okay well maybe i should just get a
finger in my ass at 40. i sent another
diagram i can't hurt right
no no couldn't
i sent him another image of the
procedure and discord if you're curious
i don't know if we could show it but it
might help sway you
bro that's can i show that
i don't know
i mean it's an illustration but
his whole hand is in the ass
so so what what
so what i think is happening is he puts
all four fingers in his [ __ ]
and then the thumb
you use that for leverage on the bottom
of the ass and apparently you do
something there yeah you got the thumb
on the cheek
like that bro
look they they added some pubic hairs on
the top you see that maybe oh yeah that
is interesting well maybe on another
round of smell my finger we can do
something like this you know
that'd be a be an odd scent
all right well now what i'm going to do
is insert four fingers up your [ __ ]
[Music]
yeah that's an interesting diagram i
don't know how they got
four in there
interesting
bro when there's a will
yeah just
yeah
uh
so okay this
there's so much guys
what do we say next this is a good thing
but hello
yes sir oh my goodness having too much
fun today
let's thank we have one sponsor so let's
thank them real fast thank you to
hellofresh you get farm fresh
pre-portioned ingredients and seasonal
recipes delivered right to your doorstep
skip trips to the grocery store and
count on hella fresh to make home
cooking easy fun and affordable and
that's why it's america's number one
meal kit super troopers love
hella fresh and these are all pictures
we've gotten
from our community and boy it all looks
healthy
delicious
and
like kind of gourmet af too oh wait
what's that one
can you peel back the burrito there a
little bit
get
is that wait is that the face of jesus
the grill mark
oh whoa you know i see something
different every time i actually see
george washington's face on that one
do you see it kind of
where this one yeah
no no that one like his profile like you
can see his powdered white hair kind of
like is this that's his nose toes okay
yeah i do see it you see what i'm saying
it's the bust of george washington
yeah and then there's the neckline huh
i don't know if
did you do that did you know about that
you do that on purpose tip
no do you have a protective do you have
a grill with little george washington
on them no no no okay wow this is
[ __ ] fascinating
but uh
to get
take it in everybody here's the top
right with your eyes first before your
mouth these days
yeah but uh anyway besides this burrito
there's also a lot of other great meals
you know you can choose from over 55
weekly options featuring pre-portioned
high-quality ingredients picked at peak
ripeness hellafresh delivers fresh
quality produce from the farm straight
to your door in less than a week so you
can savor the summer flavors right from
home
and select meals from the taste of
summer series that are sure to become
everyone's new favorite
like the old bay shrimp and sausage boil
and family style grilled steak lettuce
wraps
uh you know i love hello fresh the
reason i love hello fresh is just can
you show the meals instead of just the
super close with the burrito
the reason i love these is because
it's easy to cook whether you're a
experienced chef or not it's great
and if you're not really experienced
it's really good because you can learn
your way around the kitchen in a way
that's really impossible to mess up and
the food is always amazing so so good
think about it dude um i love hello
fresh super troopers love hella fresh
and here's the best part go to
hellofresh.com
h3tv16
and use the code h3tv16 for 16 free
meals
across seven boxes and three free gifts
that's uh hellofresh.com
h3tv16 use the code h3 tv16 for 16 free
meals
america's number one meal kit it's hello
fresh thank you
all right
yeah so
look i understand that us talking about
keemstar at this point it's almost
become like a meta
a meta meme it's more about us than it
is him at this point you know what i
mean dan
it's like it's it's more about it's all
like a conversation with ourselves it's
become meta it's taken on a life of its
own yeah like the way that we can
analyze his syrup and beef jerky but
it's great i mean it's fantastic yeah
yeah
but he's upset he's not happy
he's calling me a stalker now and can
you believe that's great it's been
absolutely lovely i love it you know
he's called he's called me
ethan klein
talk about stop i'm i'm not even allowed
to look at his twitter account i'm
banned
um
what i love about keemstar by the way
he's known for ruthlessly covering
people he's done it to me in the past
when i didn't talk about him for years
he's actually done it that you know two
one person actually uh unfortunately on
alive themselves and uh other ones were
close by their own uh admission
basher and fousey both said that they
were
uh wanted to un-alive themselves thanks
to his absolutely ruthless coverage
so i just think it's a little funny that
uh all of a sudden i'm a stalker but
okay let's just see what he has to say
let's be oh false ensured i mean the
vibes are immaculate
yeah really cross the line a four year
old in a full scent shirt and a bandana
down his eyebrows it's all good
to vibe right now
it is
but this is this is just at this point
it's it's like the uh
wow wow what you know the song i'm doing
benny hill benny hill yes
i feel like it's just a benny hill meme
at this point it's just
i don't know if that makes sense but it
does in my mind
we gotta talk about stalking all right
this is on the level of [ __ ] stalking
all right mike okay now let's try to
catch some uh look in his mirror as
glass did we see anything interesting in
the reflection
i saw funny um
post on the subreddit
so you can see by the way there's no
selfie stick yep here you can see he
well he has good hand i feel like maybe
he took notes um on our criticism of the
the angle coming in from behind and over
the shoulder that he was doing the other
day it looks more natural this is much
more natural this is a big improvement
over what we were seeing recently so
now i'm not going to say
listen i don't like the guy
but i will say that uh he has incredible
camera control yeah i mean i'll give him
that oh without a question you know
and that's the only thing i'll give him
doing some twirls in this video yeah
it's incredible
this is a flex like a ballerina almost
the agility of a ballerina yeah
stalking all right my girlfriend she
just gets a bunch of like death threats
and hate all the oh stop it she didn't
get any death i mean listen i i
i don't remem i don't think we said
anything bad about brantley his his uh
we have never
gone out of our way to dunk on her
because no of course not she's the
victim she's a 19 year old girl we have
no issue with her she's the reason we
talk about it in the first place is
because he's decreed we're just worried
about the well-being or that's what
we're expressing you know yeah dude and
if anybody watching this did go say
something to her stop
dude leave brantley alone she's the
victim in all this bro like we support
you brentley
we i i don't i have nothing bad to say
about you do you like i think that
you're
you're young
and you seem very nice and sweet and i
think that you know we have to protect
you i think you are being taken
advantage of yeah i think you're a
trooper like i could never
be in your shoes so god bless what we
care about the most is that you are
respected yes and that you are taken
seriously and that you are treated well
are you being treated well brantley no
see i don't even want to but anyway
listen we got no problem and this this
is how he spins like we're like some
monsters like we're getting people to
hate on brently we love brantley i mean
listen we we can help you uh
if you need it we're here for you
our door is always open to you
uh
all of a sudden and i she goes to me she
goes i bet ethan made a video sure
enough you did you've been stalking my
girlfriend's instagram
bro it's a public forum okay
can we talk about that little grab of
the railing right there sure yeah let's
go let's back it up
oh nice little dainty little grab there
hang on oh sure enough you did you've
been stalking
love that for you
do you think he was going to lose his
balance he needed it he gets so into
character that he started this video
talking to you like you're a child and
so now i don't know i think he really
believes like his phone is the child in
this scenario in his head so he kind of
like
leaned down like a
parent can you
i'm just thinking back i don't think we
ever addressed or said
anything negative about her right i
don't know if we can go back and look at
it
i'm pretty sure of it
yeah okay my girlfriend's instagram
don't you have a wife bro don't you have
a wife and you're the the conversations
you have you're literally having a
debate with your little yes man on your
[ __ ] podcast whether or not i hold my
phone or i have a [ __ ] stance okay
now here this is interesting
when you look in the mirror
you can really see how
it goes down
so it's interesting the part like his
knees are bent i find that interesting
he's stanced up dude i'm gonna study
this this is amazing i'm honestly
jealous
he's looking like looking like the
sasquatch yeah definitely like
yeah
he's like the runt of the sasquatch he's
the little one
never found a mate
but that's that's the interesting
posture he has there that that actually
explained that answers a lot of the
questions yeah yeah
it's like in a ready stance
look at that shot that's the best shot
we're ever gonna get at this oh he's
showing us that's what he's he's doing
on purpose now
this is this is all this is fake news
though
i gotta pull up the old video this is
not the same
angle this is not the same angle you're
you're debating us you're being
deceptive right now i i don't know dan i
kind of might have no no no no no
it was you could see his [ __ ] back it
was from behind the head yeah pull it up
yeah get a phone the axis of the arm was
behind the shoulder it was incredible
you grab it grab it
let's analyze it
but yeah i do i mean it didn't want to
do that i didn't want to have i know but
he doesn't usually show well he sticks
it on the left side of his face always
and arches the eyebrow every time okay i
mean there was a point where he turned
his back like that but
let's see let's the proof is in the
pudding as they say we'll see what dan
can produce
phone bro i hold my phone
the reason why
you know
when i make these videos or whatever
with me holding my phone the reason why
the the videos are so smooth is because
i have hand-eye coordination and that is
the same reason why you won't box me
keemstar shut up
box you
yeah bro that angle is not right
you can see his back that's what i'm
saying you can literally see wait that
doesn't make any sense av you've got to
continue
hold on i gotta get my phone out
there's no [ __ ] way
you have to see my back to that degree
i'd have to hold it like this like
behind your head
but like it's so steady can you see your
back
yes yeah but look how cause
gimbal for an arm that's why
it's the hand-eye coordination i guess
oh my god this is so funny i don't know
dan has a point bro that angle is wild
this is a completely different angle
this is not the same angle there's like
a full 30 degrees
further behind him
because we know how that's gonna end
look if you're not gonna box me fine but
the stalking the the like the like
stalking every little aspect of my life
is weird you've got to understand this
comes off weird
not just to my fans not just to the rest
of the world it's always been weird to
them
to your own fans
it's strange it's very very odd i don't
know
yeah
i think you raised a really good point
about his arm being back uh
you know
it's hard to say
i really don't know i think he might
still use a selfie stick yeah i have
been caught in 4k
yeah but anyway um brantley was also
calling us out and a girl i just want to
say
i don't know that looking at someone's
public instagram page
counts as stalking but
okay i guess your definition is pretty
loose
brantley posted this she said talk about
us until your voice is lost and your
lips fall off kind of like your career
sick
so sad but just for men's crispy that
day dude that is and too yo that that
just for men that is huh but just for
men man just really baby crispy my guy
oh yeah do you think he face tuned his
face absolutely well that's all in his
defense maybe she did
now
i just find it a little odd that okay
you said my career fall off that's fine
i mean
whatever
i'm just saying i'm curious last house
thing you know what i mean
i'm curious like what numbers bandana he
decides to wear on what day like does he
wash him
is it like does he have an array of them
i think he probably watches them we got
a whole group of them yeah yeah yeah
uh to whom it may concern we all know
who she says
oh then so i guess she shows this as
proof you got dragged on age three today
they talked about you today i don't
conceive those as death threats but okay
yeah
at all but also they would definitely
show the worst of the worst if there was
a death threat yeah unlike when they
were attacking lena when we didn't even
work for you
you know and other people who don't have
any following who he went after
yeah i mean literally it's bread and
butter to harass people on the internet
yeah that's way so funny
like what what happened to what happened
to the good old days xbox live [ __ ]
talking on the internet i thought this
was your game dude i thought you loved
doing it i'm not even
listen listen i'm not even [ __ ] talking
i'm just
like it's like a nature documentary we
are here in the pursuit of truth and
knowledge right yeah brantley continues
she says like he could never pull
someone that's young and pretty or just
pretty in general it's [ __ ] awesome
that she uses young as as like uh
that's a plus
for keemstar beautiful
well again i i don't wanna i don't even
wanna make it young
but that really says it all he doesn't
even real like
she doesn't realize
what she's saying is exactly the point
you won't be young for long and then you
will be gone you understand that right
like that
he likes teenage girls you're not going
to be a teenager in a couple years and
you will be gone out of his life yeah i
i hope you realize that that that is
that is why this right away is a gross
situation and that is why we make fun of
him
and it's a maturity mismatch he has a
power
but whatever
i just it's like
it's just funny man how it really goes
to his values right he can never pull
someone this young
excuse me right
right
it's
then she continues identify the issue
right there
i'm just going to assume this is kind of
keemstar coming through because she goes
it's because she wants me so bad
i would never ever lower my standards
anyway
um it's pretty obvious he's mad because
he ended up the way he is
he also has so much drama going on so of
course he's going to talk about someone
that doesn't give a flank [ __ ] about his
ugly ass
um
well
first of all stay keep ela out keep ela
out of it
okay
but anyway you're a good girl
you do your thing just we're here for
you if you need us blink twice
blink twice if you need help we're
yellow in the next video
yeah we're yellow in your next video
girl
is that the britney thing yeah oh yeah
wait so
going back to the brittany thing she was
actually wearing yellow yeah we now know
that was real yeah
that's so epic
and now she's showing her titty and vag
on instagram shout out god love her
that's the best outcome for brittany it
was like free brittany and then one year
later tits and dick and [ __ ]
britney's freed herself [ __ ]
oh my god
holy [ __ ] well [ __ ] balls eh
yeah holy [ __ ] balls
you go girl
you preach
anyway love it
i live for it
um he's my muse in a way you might even
say it
just like
inspires me every day
um
austin postponed his fight i mean who
gives a [ __ ] at this point yeah we
mentioned it on friday but there's a
video now
it's confirmed
you guys can suck a fat donut bro i'm
gonna i need to get that donut out
because you
ended up scamming me again
you promised us we get admission to your
fight bro
i think it's gibb's fault
i think austin's innocent
justice for austin justice for austin
you know what's funny though look at his
uh on his instagram so this is the video
that he posted explaining that the
fights postponed
here is his pinned
post it's still dead in the event should
probably unpin this one because
this
all these videos are about how it's
cancelled
no more talk
july 30 picture
i genuinely think that either
i think they didn't sell enough tickets
to be honest
i don't think anyone really cares about
this fight
i mean
i haven't really heard almost anything
about it outside of us talking about him
why do you have et what's going on here
elliot
he's rocking red hoodie because i'm
wearing a red hoodie today
this is actually this is ironically the
keem hoodie actually
oh
you're cold or what it was cold in here
earlier it's like a weirdly mild day in
l.a today for uh
late july where it's usually like 100
degrees it's like 75 outside today we
were blasting the ac in here
because
it's summer
and it got cold i got a little
compliment i feel that i feel shut up
saturday was 85 in here yeah
gross nasty
well let's just hear him out this date
is officially postponed
gabe has made it out to la he's here now
he has to go through more medical exams
unfortunately
it is unclear on what his conditions are
or what he's going through at the moment
we just hope that
he
can get cleared for
our new date which as of right now is
set for early september
if he is unable to pass his medical
exams i have no choice other than to
find a new opponent
if anyone's up for the challenge hit me
up maybe we already still hope you're
done while you're out
to this man why is he acting like there
isn't like a worthy competitor already
i'll do it just to help him out at this
point he looks like he was crying in
this video what if you got a lot of what
if there's a lot of guac he said he'll
pay you 5 million bucks
i'll do it for free austin i mean he
will never get the money
we just have to plug the podcast yeah
you do it for free now you got to get a
little block out of it it looks like it
said 5 million bucks
no problem just like bryce hall
early september
everyone
stand by all right so yes stand by stand
back and stand by
we're all waiting on yours
uh
cam already made a graphic for the fight
is that right
and discord
oh here we go yeah we already have the
graphics bro you don't have to do [ __ ]
like we'll take care of the marketing
from here
we'll we yeah we'll take it from here
dude a b versus mick broom god i hate
that photo title match
[Laughter]
it's not that bad
with the back rail cut out it's not as
bad
uh
courthouse interaction eh so oh yeah i
saw this
hard i don't really know what to make of
this is like bizarro lawyer talk
this is my oldest son he's 16 and about
an inch taller than me
uh yeah going into court right now for
his fourth violation of probation let's
see if he walks out i don't think he's
gonna know you think you're gonna walk
out
no you don't think he's gonna walk out
that sucks
let's go
what the [ __ ] was that it's just a peek
in this the world is pretty wild oh
there's just a kind of a wild world we
live in yeah
you think like outside of our bubble
because like we're all fairly well
adjusted people i feel like
and then there's this guy
and he's magga by the way i'm sure of it
just give some context
all right little uh a little
heartwarming moment between between
father and son therefore
james charles coping again
living for this
his [ __ ] is being sold in like marshalls
for like two bucks or something and he's
he's spinning it into a big dub
17 that's so pricey how much was that
[ __ ] original price tag you know olivia
i think like 35 and the mini was like 20
something
and so
this is the full one unless i have maybe
it's more let me sister uh where are you
oh it says compare at 23. it's not even
that big of a discount
it's 40 on amazon yeah
oh from 40 to 16 well that's pretty good
that's pretty close that's a fat
discount i've been talking this video
hundreds of times as if my palette being
sold in tj maxx is supposed to be super
embarrassing
maybe i'm weird but like
i don't see it that way in fact i
honestly think it's like really cool
loki uh no
[Music]
that is a department store for clearing
out [ __ ] no one wants to buy i mean
i don't know it's not a dub
it's definitely not a dub it's a
womp
i mean it's not really cool
you could say i get it it's part of the
nature of business yeah i wouldn't say
it's really cool though like kardashian
[ __ ] probably winds up in tj maxx
eventually right
where's all that [ __ ] sell out
what the [ __ ]
probably not probably not probably not i
mean there's there's always big brands
in those stores though i'm not yeah i'm
not too hyped to the makeup general i
suppose are you a max and easter dad
a max and easter yeah your maximum me
and eli should go there all the time you
can find really great stuff there oh
yeah
i'm not going to shame anybody for
shopping at t.j.maxx i'm a maximum
ross
i see people saying i love tj maxx yeah
tj maxx and ross was my [ __ ] marshalls
those are all super fun stores
it's like you never know what to find
either which is so fun
get some deals there dude
yeah get some pallets bear
get some diamond water i always see that
there
it's incredible
somebody said kylie and kim's stuff ends
up there all the time oh okay i
that's just the chatter saying that but
no i believe him set
i believe him
ella is four years old if you really
think about it most makeup products
launch that are popular for like
four minutes is that right olivia pretty
fair fair the fact that four years later
this was his only product to be fair
right this was the big one yeah how is a
literal miracle
millions of people have gotten their
hands on this palette which is the
biggest blessing that i could ever ask
for nothing can be popular forever so of
course years later it's going to be sold
to stores like this because the brand's
got to get rid of the stock that's just
how business works
now whether you love me or hate me you
can get a great formula for a super
super affordable price so
who cares
my contract is up i bought my house with
this palette i bought my parents a house
with this palette my makeup line i've
developed with the money that i made
from this palette
i'm forever grateful for what this
palette did but i've moved on and so
should everybody
don't tell me to move on you move on
don't you [ __ ] tell me to move on i
was gonna say that's kind of whatever
like he's making a good point and then
he gotta tell me what to do
you can't just let it slide please
i think he just wanted to make a
shirtless tick-tock and he just found
something there's trapping yeah yeah
i just feel like someone needs to tell
him these vids aren't
helpful but um
because he's got a point to be honest
yeah right i didn't think it i think
it's kind of reasonable i know i know
we're all about the james charles
slanderer on this podcast oh but uh it's
it's actually
but the thing is um
that his house and his parents house and
all that i think it's all on the table
if a lawsuit happened so
yeah really sad wait what lawsuit
if a lawsuit happens of misconduct
that's definitely a civil
i see oh
[Music]
i don't know
millions of those though yeah whoa so he
probably made it when he was like
that was before any of the scandals or
anything i had one i yeah i believe it i
mean i don't i don't judge you for that
it was a huge deal wait you think he
sold me okay so he's like set for life
that's why he's like all good
from just that one palette well that and
also like his youtube because youtube is
getting 10 million views
yeah but that's true but i think that
pales in comparison when you sell 2
million of anything
you know beauty creators
the kardashians advertising the merch
ripped off from you guys
yeah
yeah it's kind of crazy like he could
have had it all yeah he was on the path
to be
this global brand bro
uh if he sold for 50 bucks 2 million
that's
100 million in revenue
goddamn
buy buy a yak farm if you wanted to but
it's funny
but he i think he's working with
department stores so that's half right
out the gate it's a basically 50 split
on that
okay that's down to
uh somehow it's more
what happened
whoa oh i did free money glitch i did
50. why did i do five anyway times
divided by two idiot
phone with me
50 million i didn't need a calculator
for that
and then you know you take out
the cost of making the goods which is
probably
about you know
30
which puts you around maybe
35 million
i think it's possible he made 35 million
bucks from that
that's a lot of cheddar that's a lot of
cheddar cheese maybe like 10 mil and
hush money
and he paid off 10 million hush money so
minus
right 10 for that get out
carry the one so 25.
which is close to what it says on google
says he's worth 22 million i think
that's actually a pretty pretty solid
guess
there you go man i got to make a palette
yeah would you guys buy an ethan palette
yep
there you have it
that's how shane dawson first started
getting into youtube
is during his jeffree star thing he was
like
would you guys buy a shane palette and
then it took off from there love that
so yeah because he never wore makeup or
does wear makeup no he didn't that's so
interesting yeah so you don't even need
to care about makeup to do a palette
yeah you could do it right now
you guys want a palette
well let's remember
what happened immediately after it's a
curse isn't it yeah anyone who sells
pallets is cursed forever yeah tati
shane
uh there was that one other lady game
that had like the jaclyn hill yeah yo
the palette curse is real maybe skip the
palette
oh my god people actually want me to do
it though look at them they want the
ethan palette
it's cursed
yo pesto palette i'm seeing
a pesto green with fire there would be
some h3 theme colors olivia could uh
model it
sure
olivia could help us engineer it she's
the makeup uh queen
[ __ ]
actually it's so cool we're going to
make a palette it goes directly to tj
maxx oh nice we skipped the middle man
yeah
and we go tj maxx exclusive can we go
lower what
who does tj maxx dump their uh product
to uh the pacific ocean i believe big
watts
big lots yeah i
uh
island of the pacific ocean oh right
yeah big lots [ __ ] schlapps dude
don't they just sell food i don't know
they got great deals on paper towels
it's just like
they just have random [ __ ] yeah i think
it really is that i think it's like
target and places like in walmart it's
like a half they just dump all of their
uh unsold stock on the big lots dollar
store i don't know do you guys have
plato's closet out here
plato's closet yeah nah what kind of
stuff later it buys back your clothes
oh there's a bunch of places oh we have
places like that yeah buffalo exchange
yeah
they buy back here you [ __ ] and then
sell it like more than it would cost
retail yeah yo
wasteland
that one they super overpriced
yeah that place got bad i don't know so
that's fun shout out james charles on
his exclusive uh collab with tj maxx
what is this plastic surgery tick tocker
gets dragged
from strangers i've seen a lot of these
vids and and things and she was on him
[ __ ] this like pissed me off when i saw
it i've seen this is like a whole trend
of plastic surgeons to make like videos
analyzing celebs and trying to guess the
work they had
sometimes they're on and sometimes i
feel like they're stretching it now i
don't think worse than that have you not
seen this yet i have not seen this woman
this is
this is not what you just described this
is actually worse than that now if i had
to guess i don't think she has any work
done
she doesn't yeah i mean
i know and that's a problem according to
this lady oh she's oh [ __ ] yep that's
the angle
wait no
it gets worse
no this video pissed me off she's like
yo you need work yep
[Music]
love it let's go
[Music]
all right guys let's talk about natalya
dyer from stranger things first of all
she killed it in stranger things and if
you don't like stranger things we cannot
be friends so if i was natalia's
injector this is what i would do we
start by treating those masseters and we
all know how much i love treating
masseters to help slim the face next i
would actually add a little bit of
dude you're ruining her she is a famous
actress she has distinctive like face
bone cheek she's very beautiful
you're gonna [ __ ] destroy her face
you're gonna make her look there's like
a whole race of women and peace and love
i i don't need to offend anyone but like
what happens when women go in and get
these all this work done they all start
to look the same
there's like a whole race of women
that are like look the same right like
this
well it's like how they the lips all the
kardashians look like the same per i
can't tell them apart anymore and they
really didn't used to look that and and
to me it's just it's so unattractive
because
like conventionally these women are
usually very beautiful
they're like extremely fit they take
great care of their bodies and stuff but
they start to look like
like an ai sex robot and i i mean that
like
not you know not in like a
like take advantage of them way but i'm
just saying like they start to look and
it's like they have no individuality
anymore they almost just want to be like
they're just looking for i don't know i
don't know i don't make it so i'm just
but it's just weird okay you [ __ ] ass
that's not working no you can't even
imagine like going on tick tock and
seeing someone talk about everything
wrong with your face yeah you get stuff
so uninvited yeah like [ __ ] off she's
like hey this is doctor
i love stranger things if i was god i
would have made this girl look like this
yeah what the hell
also all the young girls watching that
uh thinking and drawing parallels to
their own face
right seeing this this but by the way
she has like a perfect face she's so
beautiful yeah like nothing absolutely
she does not need any work just get like
a busted up
no girl don't do it at all not that he's
getting an ugly celebrity yeah at least
get an ugly sweater and do it to them
kidding
just kidding she's so [ __ ] beautiful
um
but at the end of the day she doesn't
have work unless uh people have mental
illness
that's just how it works but you know i
think look there's nothing wrong with
getting some botox and and picking up
your face and stuff it's not personally
something i would do for myself
but um i think people grace
age more gracefully when they don't get
work done for the most part although
some i think sometimes they can do a
good job i don't i don't know but like
there's this whole
trend the filler it's the filler it's
like the lip filler the cheek filler the
[ __ ] it's out of control yeah i mean
i kind of agree but
you know it's a personal choice and if
it makes people if it helps their
self-esteem or whatever then so be it
like you know i when i was younger i
like was really hung up on thinking
plastic surgery was like [ __ ] up
um but i've come around to the idea that
it really does help a lot of people when
they're really insecure about themselves
and everything and
by all means but but to
unsolicited
uh you know deconstruct like what's
wrong with your face like this is like
that's a whole another level like don't
don't do that
at least yeah yeah there you have it but
anyway let's keep watching a chin filler
just to help fill out her filler make
her face more of like a heart-shaped
neck chin filler she got like i'm
okay
she's a powerful chin
what are you feeling it up to
next i would add a little bit to the
lips just a little bit nothing crazy
just a nice pouch she's turning her into
she's trying to turn her into the bimbo
race if natalya wants to do this let
natalia do this just
stop talking about it like she's like
ask i just like how she's like if a
woman with a perfect face came in asking
for work i want to turn her away this is
what i would do right i wouldn't be like
girl you're
well i guess
yeah fill that [ __ ] bag up
wow
young girls watch this and they're like
oh noted okay so that's what that's what
i'm gonna aspire to be that's what's
wrong with my cheeks like what the hell
there's a reason [ __ ]
there's a reason like uh
mental illness went up when instagram
and [ __ ] like that became popular yeah
it's so [ __ ] up especially for younger
girls
but also younger dudes too probably well
yeah i mean photoshop's the main reason
for that i think
people like russia they like airbrush
their skin
their titties their hips yeah people
look like perfect guys too i mean
everyone on there is like jacked
super skinny instagram and tick tock the
best way to meet girls
oh okay sean
keep me out of this conversation
and then we'd get in there and do a
little bit of botox i'd give her a nice
brow lift to help open up her eyes
and to top it off we'd start working
with some sculptra
hey cam can you do me a favor
photoshop her after she's done with her
and we can do a before and after oh she
does she does it ah
i seem to have more thin skin and we
want to prevent that from getting
thinner and create more collagen all
right she has perfect skin
i would kill for skin that perfect see
what the final product would give us
[ __ ] you are not serious no
you are not serious get that away
that's a stranger thing monster what the
[ __ ] get out stop don't stop
that looks all right like my photoshop
skills
as you can tell her jaw is slimmer her
chin is more pointy he's a different
person than not the same person
she's a different person hate to say it
worse
obviously worse beautiful before she's
still beautiful less so i think in the
in the photoshop
a little bit scary
damn you're using photoshop wrong dude
you gotta have fun
give her like three eyes that would be
fun
here we're thinking of adding a third
eye on the forehead
t and her eyebrows are more lifted and
gotta love that pout
comment below with your thoughts
dude hell no
no
i was diagnosed as delusional so i came
home and went to bed
[Laughter]
oh no
i don't think that she understands what
exactly it is she's doing nope
but uh man this is such an album post do
we love it do we hate it we hate it
we all hate it i hate it
um i can never be this handy by the way
this post has 11 million views that's
pretty crazy i could never be a
celebrity because if someone made a
video like this about me i would get
violent
that's funny
that's true oh this is
this is the same woman
when you're having a conversation with
someone but can't help but count how
many units of botox they need
she jesus lady i'm selling like she's a
waitress man
why am i still getting hate
that's kind of crazy thing to admit
okay shout out do your thing girl
you do you
but you can't be seriously tell us that
you think that this is a good job
and this is with photoshop you have
don't really have this level of control
with botox and [ __ ]
[ __ ]
that's crazy
cam can you do one i want to see your
version
i don't her photoshop skills are not
that good so let's see what you can do
uh
oh you got it already
let's okay here's cameron so we're
adding a now that's pretty giant third
eye to the forehead this is cool this is
fun
that's an interesting body mod
[Music]
can i get this work done i hope
probably i mean just yeah you that's
just a body mod you could probably get
it done if you're really committed hell
yeah
thank you cameron
he's the best for a reason
okay so guys it might be happening now
fresh and fit been trying to debate us
forever and he wanted to bring rolo tony
browntown [ __ ] announcement i'm gonna
make
but now he's teaming up with andrew tate
to try and debate us uh did you dm them
who dimmed him i didn't idea did they
respond to check right now still no
response these guys are such clowns such
cowards
here they he put out a dog he put out a
declaration
and we damned him and said let's hop on
zoom with t tate and fit
because after i saw hassan talk with
them i was like you know what i'm gonna
make
i think we can
i think we could have a [ __ ]
announcement an interesting conversation
with them
oh by the way it's hassan's birthday
today oh happy birthday hassan
outstanding delight
37 today is he no wait how old is he
he's 31. oh he's young what the [ __ ]
god i hate them the oldest person i'm so
old nobody's older than me
oh [ __ ] old how old is casey neistat
keemstar is older than me casey neistat
i think is
40 about double check okay good old ass
piece of [ __ ]
loser he started yeah he's 41. casey
started vlogging every day i think when
he was 35 that dude is oh it sucks to be
him bro
do we have a list of oldest youtubers
can we pull that up
um
wikipedia oldest youtubers it's just i
just googled it and it's just a picture
no no no no no no no there's one lady
that's 106 years old okay
jimmy lee is right 85. what's going on
no no i see you type my name in the
search bar nice try
nice try
hey get that stop
37.
[Music]
all right come on
come on guys
so here they go they're calling us out
i'm gonna make right now
bro you serious with the record scratch
i can't believe he actually does that he
queues himself up with a record scratch
hassan ethan h3 all you ass clowns over
there me and andrew what's up i spoke
with the
okay because tay was telling me that
y'all like to mute the mics
okay
so if you guys who who says we mute mics
well he's talking he he's talking about
hassan
but
hassan
he's an idiot he doesn't know he doesn't
know how any of it works hassan doesn't
have the ability to mute his mic
this okay
because tay was telling me that y'all
like to mute the mics oh taint
yeah wait did he he said tate was
telling me you all like to mute the mics
but that is
100 not anything neither he wasn't in
charge of the
hassan it wasn't even on hassan yeah
that's what i mean it was on his stream
but it wasn't his discord call what did
i mean he was like joining to mute it
yeah
oh yeah that just takes excuses
you only dominated me because his mic
was louder just straight beta behavior
dude it should be anywhere anytime
you know what i mean on site
okay
sometime if you guys aren't cowards like
i've already proven through the dm's and
everything else
bro you're such a liar we just dmd
you've been dodging getting on the call
with us for like what it feels like
years
such a liar bro
insecure
why are we even entertaining these guys
i mean i do want i think at this point
in time me and hassan getting on call
with those two goons
could be a could be a beautiful thing
and not for them but i think like
like i saw how hassan really exposed
andrew
and it wasn't i think it's possible you
can really get him
sure
and so i think i'd be willing to talk to
him
but uh
it's all shenanigans from him you'll
debate us you're welcome to come here to
miami hell we'll even cover y'all
[ __ ] flights or whatever sometimes
it's expensive so generous get some
points on mx you're so nice martin all
right
well you can't be you can't actually
think that we give a [ __ ] that much to
fly to florida you idiot can i can i
look up flights for the whole crew and
be like all right by the way this is our
place yeah we're bringing 19 people
so you're so nice byron that's so nice
mike thanks for the free version so nice
byron yeah and uh business obviously
because
it's a business uh travel yeah thank you
so to be about what like 50 60 000 maybe
a little more
flights are right now
come on
now put it up and then load them get on
there
you guys are more than welcome to come
here to miami we could do it here y'all
want to wear masks because you guys are
scared of coping fantastic
six feet apart if you guys want to do it
all right i'll tell you what and you can
even wear a mask if you want to
i usually don't let my guests come in
here with masks
so i don't want no [ __ ] excuses
you guys bro what are you talking about
i have a family i have a job i have kids
i have do four podcasts a week we run a
a company a company
what are you talking about no excuses
you think that i really give a [ __ ]
about you to fly to florida you [ __ ]
this is like the tin pool thing where
it's like
invite them to do super unreasonable
thing we can just do it over zoom why
are you being such a [ __ ]
beta behavior
that was the original whole back and
forth is we were like let's jump on a
zoom call and they're like no we want to
do it in person
we'll come out to la we're like great
are you guys vaccinated they said yes
that's your cards and they said no i
forgot about that and we were like okay
well
just black out any personal information
then and then they and then
they backed off so
such absolute [ __ ]
morons yeah they were gonna they were
gonna fly out here and come in person
pretty gracious offer
just show us you're vaccinated bro
and he was gonna lie he was gonna lie
and come here on facts during like a
high pandemic situation
that's pretty illegal
trying to kill me [ __ ] [ __ ] and el assan
make these dumb ass arguments of women
are better drivers because they're safer
sir we already proved that your argument
is weak and does not make sense because
men are more skilled for drivers which
is what tate was referring to in the
first place that's not what he said
he actually no if that's what he meant
and said what he would have said
how do you quantify skill idiot
how come they cut out rolo tony
browntown did they realize he's full of
[ __ ] he's nobody cares about rollo
andrew taints like
got swag at least people watch him rolo
tony is like literally nobody
what are you afraid of ian
what are you afraid of ian
[ __ ] i love rolo though that was a great
meme of the past
rollo tony brown town catch yourself
right at the door
you know you got some rolos you know you
gotta give me some more
of those roll-ups
such a jam bro tim heidecker
is the top g yeah i have this discussion
with you guys we're going to talk about
intersectional dynamics we're going to
talk about you know since you guys are
so mad about oh you red pill guys are
wait what did you want to discuss he was
referring to in the first place we'd be
happy to have this discussion with you
guys we're going to talk about
intersectional dynamics intersexual
dynamics okay oh my god like can we talk
about like the political and economic
state of the world thank you
okay intersex dynamics okay we're gonna
talk about you know since you guys are
so mad about oh you red pill guys or
himself blah blah blah we'd be happy to
debunk all of your thought processes on
how men and women are equal and how you
think we're the same
men and women women are equal
and also they're [ __ ] that the left
has to believe i would love to debate
you guys because hassan i've watched you
debate you don't know what the [ __ ]
you're talking about ethan you're just
playing stupid if i'm going to be honest
with you
okay all right
then hop on zoom let's make it happen
oh and fred and by the way fresh you're
too [ __ ] dumb to even enter the
conversation and you want to fly in the
cow man
load up them down
the canyon like that with a boom
just trying to recall what day it is
this whole time he's talking
it is wednesday
it sure is wednesday actually no it's
monday
someone tell fresh it's monday yeah
we can
[Laughter]
[Music]
just say by the way it's monday yeah i
got you wednesday
but yeah listen you and andrew just come
on it'll be fun
we'll all get lots of views you guys
will can make your compilations your
epic dub compilations and
whatever and then andrew can just end
every point he makes with look that's my
opinion that's your opinion i can
believe what i want and you could choose
not to believe what i want
moving on to a more happy topic
as my friendship is blossoming
with mike
uh mad max
malach mike malach that's it right
yeah
i believe so yeah malach mike malach
jeff whitake and tana
mongeau mojo mojo that's actually mojo
see i have trouble i i asked olivia like
what's the proper pronunciation for last
name because i never knew
um yeah you guys always said mongu yeah
and also mage likes kind of difficult to
pronounce too yeah these guys need to
maybe just maybe they need staging
yeah
maybe that would be a good place to
start stage names maybe
yeah well widdick's got a good name so
jeff whitaker easy to donate that and
that and there's a reason he's my bestie
right it's a solid name
strong name
well anyway
my friendship with the three of them is
blossoming in fact we have a date on the
record
on the calendar for them to all come on
did we say that already or no
i don't think so i don't think we
confirmed the date
didn't we let me check you didn't
confirm the date but you uh
[Music]
okay okay so right now
as it stands because i guess mike's out
of town so we're waiting for the whole
crew to be here
wednesday august 3rd
is going to be
is going to be
the best friends
reuniting
after being separated
what the bff podcast
the bff podcast that already exists i
[ __ ] my pants the bff you'll have the
name the bff because there's
well there's four of us so bff right
right i'm sorry what was that
yeah so anyway
tana was never really in the running
right
tana well for best friend stuff why not
i thought no she was jeff
there was one other with peace and love
contestant
philly philly d
that was always a long shot philly
let's be real
anyway here we go nice things are being
said
about me
by the three of them
100 from rory
the mole people would like to see ethan
and hassan curb stomp these fools
i their humble emissary just get
nauseous from the cringe radiation
fret and fish
cobra cobra
bait give off
so we have the backing of the mole
people shout out to the mole man
big fan of the mall people
by the way cobra tate
whether hassan or me or anyone debates
him
he's going to be irrelevant in a year we
see people like this come and go
he's he's going to burn everyone he's
going to make his money
and his stick will get old and he's just
gonna [ __ ] disappear
in like you know a year same thing
happened to tai lopez now he's just
shilling like radio shack nft and the
dude fell off flat earth take their
money
anyway let's get to the good stuff
almost doesn't count dude
should we talk about another popular
podcast out there the h3 podcast that
the host is currently fighting for our
friendship and we are fighting back i
guess i know or not i was happy for once
to not be fighting with him honestly
honestly i don't
i guess okay well you know what me too
not that he's really said anything bad
about us to be fair to him it's more
been
well zach really is the one that's taken
across with mike i'm just i'm just
stating the shame what i saw that's all
i'm stating
but you saw
yeah i i mean everyone knows this is
some [ __ ] is gym shorts
you saw that i don't know whatever
yeah we're trying to make peace here um
michael that's watching that's
defamation jack don't take it personal
did you see him [ __ ] his pants with your
eyes i mean it's like an assumption type
deal okay you need to be clear because
that is actually defamation yeah oh
forgive me forgive me yeah so you want
to correct the record why not correcting
the record now i assume he'd [ __ ] yeah
he's going to [ __ ] his gym shorts i had
a 24 hour fitness that's good and you
didn't see it no never saw it
okay that's just an assumption
that's your opinion
it's my opinion yes okay excellent
anyway yeah me too mike big mike
mikey
hey yo
my boy
michael
my dog dab me up
what's up player is that what you're
gonna say when he walks in
yeah bro big hug for my homie
tap me up dog boom best friend we gotta
film when they walk in
maybe we should try to capture the real
moment on
i usually don't like doing that because
i think it gets weird expectations but
it could be fun if i'm backstage
somewhere they can't see me and then
when the show's ready we meet for the
first time and dab the [ __ ] up on screen
yeah i think i might like that idea
maybe a little kiss on each cheek
it's so wonderful to see
he said i should he was like because i
said i was scared of him and he was like
i don't know why she'd be scared of me
like yeah yeah
i like the new soft side of of ethan bro
yeah i think that's i think that's i
mean
you know why are we all being so nice
right now are we scared what are we
doing look we have no no no no no what
are we doing with him he wants us to i
want to collab with him i want to do
brand deals with them i want to start a
new crypto exchange with them
did you get them involved in the space
yeah
yeah
[Music]
no he's being funny he's funny
he's a funny guy mike's funny
i will say he is funniest big mike
coming out here saying he's funny
tan is funny
agreed yeah
super funny
she's awesome great people honestly
that's a room of good people right there
i don't know why you guys are laughing
well i'm super pumped it's just i wasn't
i didn't expect my boss to say that this
is like a meeting of the minds people
are asking for ethan mike palette
oh oh a little clam
so you can get them off the crypto [ __ ]
and on to the power that's what i'm
saying mike drop the crypto [ __ ] it's
too sleazy you're better than that bro
it's time to rise above we flip him we
we make him betray logan and he becomes
the new co-host dude he should come be
on our show and we'll make a palette and
you don't have to show dink doink
you know
you're better than that mike
let's turn that what's his vlog called
the night watch um the night shift the
night shift let's turn the night shift
into the day shift you know what i'm
saying yeah like that just get your ass
working
during the day sleep during the night
turn you into a god-fearing
uh family man
yep
gambling yeah
dude i lie come on
putting me in my mouth i'm sponsored by
steak i think that's what we should do
here's what here's what i'm recommending
i think that we should do
i think that was an only fan sex tape
with me you tana should sit down and
have a crypto backed blackjack
tournament
so we combine all of it into one thing
and by the way hosted by faze banks
because we chop we talk in the dms and
it's kind of fun yeah and i get the vibe
that banks is like if i what if i wasn't
like associated with keem we'd be
besties
he's been a you know he was a fan he's
drifted away from kim though there's a
podcast throughout him he's just waiting
for the stench to kind of
clear out a little bit flow off him yeah
my seed is all over this place bro stop
that's so foul
you can't dude if you refer to your scum
as seed that's just not right
and that's like how it's like biblical
a man shall not spill his seed upon the
earth this place has been marked and
violated forever yeah
it sounds like he's walking into
exorcism
and co-hosted by aidan ross this way we
don't get into a bad project i believe
in this project that's a good problem
with all the money it's going to
charities
yeah that's correct that's how you save
yourself damn how would we differentiate
you from phase banks though it might get
a little tricky if we have you both in
the same room and by the way that's
actually a really good point their
voices are pretty similar eh
oh mike and phase yeah
yeah
well play the seed sound bite again
i see it is all over this place and then
mike laughing
just back just
back to back
[Music]
back to back
h3h3 humor all right thank you zach
best in the biz
i [ __ ] my pants today
[Laughter]
at the same time yeah that's valid
are they the same person are they the
same are you cloning are you okay i like
this idea of this collaboration it's
good that we're coming up what do you
like
i do like that idea though i love it
also blackjack tournament for charity
that's the title of it it's us versus
that crypto backbone no [ __ ] that it's
not it's not all services thumbnail's
ready we team up each one of us teams up
with a member of their team
bffs now that's a show i'd watch
that's like an unlikely pairing
i mix it up in there
bffs [ __ ] yeah that's actually a funny
name though [ __ ] dave pork boy and those
little kids that he does the show with
this is adults talking about adult [ __ ]
somebody said i honestly thought that
sound bite about seed was mike oh wow i
guess
oh my god our theory that people can't
tell their voice no mike's not that
gross he's got class all over this place
mike's a good guy he wouldn't say
anything that grotesque
you know
yeah i think i might just get my pants
and then tana and one of the guys that
said
women producers yeah yeah that would be
cool and then we could all have group
sex after and film it
he's doing he keeps doing the tricia
angle
right
no group sex
trust me you guys have group sex without
me it'll be better
okay i'll ruin it i'll ruin all the fun
and raise a ton more though for charity
we're starting businesses we used to be
enemies now we're best friends beautiful
look at that but i also am serious
because i know what's going to come out
of the key
but dan
i was just laughing at how he keeps
doubling down on the best friend no he
he
accepts the title yeah as do i
we're an item me and jeff
jeffrey
no dude jeff [ __ ] dude good old jeff
okay you're making them a couple
plus version with benefits pffffs with
benefits
[ __ ] yeah bro
i'm gonna come off slightly like
tongue-in-cheek no because he does the
best i can just rip a vape
yeah
okay queen
cool we we used to be enemies now we're
best friends want to see a real good day
but i also am serious because i know
it's going to come off slightly like
damn
do you see how she ripped that pretty
dope
good lung power
bro
she doesn't smoke
bar
i mean cigarettes it's gonna come off
slightly like tongue and cheek no
because he does the best friend con by
the way i don't how i lost that contest
that badly oh you got smoke no but why
though it's because you it's because you
play into it more and they know you they
don't know the real side of me there's
no
audience that seems like it should be a
kill shot to you being the best friend
wait jeff doesn't let women drive that's
an issue he's mike is right interesting
oh i've never heard that
oh what a twist does anyone know what
he's talking about um is jeff isis
you'd think he doesn't like men driving
after the day
oh
i mean he's got a point
oh my god
sorry dude i just had to
that's my best friend you're talking
about watch it look at this can we pull
this out watch it love
there's already a bff uh
thing established
wait years ago that's you yeah sure is
wait what's the context of this huh it
was at i saw her at a concert and
it was like right after all the tanacon
stuff that was the boy that she was with
but you went cheek to cheek with her
yeah she was so nice they're besties
that is really nice for about two
minutes some lady gaga tony bennett dude
going cheek to cheek is pretty oh my god
i just spilled coke all in my [ __ ]
life and that's the shirt a b bar i get
um right yeah
can i get a rag or something yeah
do not waste that sweet milk
god damn it
such an idiot
nope
um
wow that's really nice cheek to cheek
huh
yeah very kind
i'm not sure i'd be comfortable with
that
cheek to cheek it's too much contact
face to face
this was pre-covered and we're both like
teen girls i feel like thank you it'd be
different if it was you
but shout out to her i mean that's like
that's like when um princess diana shook
hands with people with aids for real i'm
the person with it
just saying it's that level of uh person
personal i mean come i mean shout out
tana wow she loves her fans man
anyway
yeah i mean why do you think jeff won so
much over mike
that's a good question
he's hotter i think it was a lot harder
i mean based off of what i see our chat
thirsting over all the time are they
thirsting over jeff all the time oh i
see it all the time i disagree i think
mike is a stud
well
the audience disagrees well hold the
[ __ ] phone zach did you just come out
and say mike is a stud after everything
yeah i think we just uncovered something
i'm i think i'm turning dude yeah yeah
we uncovered that zach realized the
guy's gonna be in the office next week
he's talking [ __ ] no this man's been in
love with mike this whole time and he's
been disguising it for just staying he
[ __ ] dude
oh my god you said he's a stud he's a
stud yeah
he's a stud
who are you i don't recognize you no he
is he's just because it doesn't mean i
necessarily hate the guy because you
know okay okay yeah yeah i mean listen
mike's dating history speaks for itself
no he just died dude he's stunned he
[ __ ] the guy the guy with you know i
mean
the guy's a [ __ ] stud man he [ __ ] i
mean lana rhodes come on
is this dead
jerry terry gary that's not easy to pull
off
no
okay so there you have it zach wow a
stud he says that's really unexpected
wow too hard whatever and i just sit
here and do my thing yeah i know i know
what you do i know what you see or you
watch kate videos you don't let women
drive which for the h3 audience that
seems like it should be a kill shot to
you being the best friend
because they want women driving you
clearly don't it's not about this
based on the new info that's just coming
out about it yeah i think that's fair
mike's actually i actually was i was
thinking the same thing mike
now that we know do we first of all can
we get some intel on on this uh jeff
doesn't want women to drive stuff
i i don't want to show that out of
context okay
also do you guys think mike is hot
i'm seeing some stuff mike love in the
chat here well pam yeah i mean
i mean zack thinks so
okay well shout the [ __ ] out dude
how does it feel to be one of the
beautiful people
about the sex it's about the age of the
person they need to understand that when
you drive a truck that's 42 years old
and the the ignition you have to gas it
a little bit and i could tell
a little bit kind of like the light that
you're gassing right now buddy keep it
up
oh
[ __ ] out of here
i'm explaining that
it's the truck's problem the truck
so jeff doesn't think women can turn a
truck on i mean this is uh this is a
problem
we respect all women at all times
let's get that pull up
what's the poll what is the who's
who is my best friend who is ethan's is
it mike or jack new best friend do you
want to throw tana in ethan i'm sorry no
not yet not yet soon mike to give mike
some credit he always points out that he
wants to make sure the audience knows
that he's not doing shtick like he's
serious
he really wants us to be best buds i
feel like he should get some credit for
that oh now you're sipping for for mike
now
i'm not the one who said i made up
seeing him [ __ ] his pants bro i never
made anything up
it's an assumption
well hold on hold on hold on let's keep
watching it's getting on the screen
everyone we're getting a little heated
everybody calm down
on this poll uh
jeff mike phase banks is wild card no he
he nobody is voting for that guy let's
just be real all right it's jeff and
peace and love faze banks best friend i
was going to say he's going
listen faze banks is on the bench okay
well they need to support
but i'm just saying it's possible
they're friends one of them only has one
good oh sorry
let's just say mike should drive hmm
[Music]
i mean yeah mike should okay so so let's
take a poll
after this new
uh
uh oh [ __ ] you guys oh my god this is
quite a term oh my god this is look
what's happening this is good
because this is insane
guys get your votes in because this
matters this might be the most important
pull we've ever done your voice deserves
to be heard guys voting is the only way
we're going to change the world get
those votes in you matter
wow it's close it's neck and neck you
guys let's keep watching and you guys
can keep the vote going right gas
lighter all right
the truck is crazy i i i turned out in
like 10 minutes go out and [ __ ] i
haven't been listening for 10 minutes i
just slid in on andrew tate
what'd you say i said hi with heart eyes
i don't even think he has an account
what she's flirting with andrew what are
you trying to get locked up
trying to get that basement spot
oh he does emery entertainment
yeah i'm gonna see what happens i i slid
in like i'm trying to [ __ ] and i want to
see what what comedic things can come
from that okay he's probably going to
try to manage her only probably going to
try to revoke your license
would you buy takes taters if there was
okay so i think that that concludes the
bff
dialogue so guys get your vote in
this is the best friend khan uh 2022
your vote matters uh rock the vote
we have nine thousand votes in
mike
jeff i don't want you to feel bad
because it was
close i don't want you to take this
personally because you know we love you
but you got saying oh sorry go ahead go
ahead love that is saying that jeff is
not missing misogynistic watch the full
podcast there there is probably more
context to that okay okay
no misogyny obviously a joke
jeff loves women and respects women
with that intel you still have time to
change your vote
we have 10 000 votes in this is
this is a big deal
yeah there's uh
a lot more than that watching right now
so
so and and you don't have to be signed
in or anything you just go over and
click you might have to be signed into
you might have to but 10 thousand that's
good that's good
this is so close guys this we don't have
to do a recount on this
i don't know how many hanging chads are
involved in this
it's they call them dumps it's
tightening
jeff if you want to call dan and ask if
he can find a few thousand more votes
now's the time i'm so dumb you know
i feel like you're being a little biased
ethan it seems like you're trying to
nudge me
a little bit no i just don't want to i
don't want
i just don't want jeff to feel bad
because it's not looking good we have 11
000 votes right now and this is so close
so jeff
it's down to it oh my god it is down to
two percent right now this is insane
y'all spread people it's like georgia
this is [ __ ] insane with 12 000 votes
in
it is
49.51 this is absolutely unprecedented
in closeness
holy smokes you guys
wow over 12 000 votes cast
i think we got to call it
[Music]
you want to call it whoa it's at 50 50.
let's call it now wait wait wait jeff is
back on top
let's get back on top or even they're
even dude no but jeff's on top what
happened justice for mike mike was up 60
40. no justice for no don't play the
music yet this is what the people said
they'll play the music
guys get your vote because jeff's on top
now this is insane
what happened to mike dude
you know what happened
no but i'm saying i'm saying
i'm saying mike now it's time to get the
calls in
do the recounts mike
this is in recount territory mike make a
call to dan
maybe he could find a few votes for you
time to storm the podcast uh big massive
dumps
this is illegal in most places passive
electioneering just so you know
that's not what i meant to be doing
i wasn't doing that i'm glad mike lost
he deserves better what is this flip
flop like
what are you saying you're giving me
[ __ ] you're like listening to the full
sentence like i'll repeat it for you
fourteen thousand can you take your
[ __ ] glasses why are you wearing
glasses inside
okay come on it's looking cool actually
i think it's cool thank you well hold on
no answers question maybe
are you trying to be like jeff
oh
answer his question maybe he you know he
deserves an answer wait a minute wait
pull up the video again you trying to be
like jeff abrams wearing a backwards hat
and glasses like that i don't think he's
wearing a hat wait wait wait wait let me
keep those
yo
here's the passive election here now
jeff's a [ __ ] badass yeah bro this is
you're flip-flopping you've got to pick
one guys 15 000 votes and i think we're
gonna have to call it this is absolutely
insane mike was in a commanding lead
60-40 something happened you know we
found out that more context on the
chauvinistic thing we re we remember the
relationship we had with mike we decided
don't throw it out don't throw away all
we have had over the years uh for a new
exciting best friend let's try to make
it work 52 percent with 15 000 votes
into 48
jeff is still my best friend we're
calling it
it's over
what man i got to tell you mike's got to
feel good he closed the gap
it was neck and neck who's neck and neck
maybe next year maybe next year mike
wow wow wow
well i think we should decide after the
podcast after they've given you given
you their gifts and uh friendship gifts
and stuff like that you're the you're
the dawn ethan they have to pay tribute
to you yeah
you come to me i gotta kiss the ring you
come to me on the day of my podcast
asking to be my best friend
here we go how dare you
the best friend will be chosen by the
audience you cannot sway the vault
[Music]
i will do this thing you ask
but there may come a time when
i may call on you for a favor
it may be the next time dink doink 2
comes out
and i might want to tip off
to get in before the rug pull
it might be the next time uh
logan takes a fall
and the third
[Music]
and there may come a time when i need to
ask for a favor
okay
got that out of my system but um wake up
then
wake up we're done
what are you taking amy what is that
prescription drug you're throwing in
your mouth what is that
that was a house
is that omaprazole
wait what actually is it in there
i was doing it for the meme i was
waiting for you to switch to me
what is in there bro uh this is uh
i can't say
well no it's pepsin oh it's just prior
sack
it's just for heartburn yeah why do you
have it in a prescription ball isn't
that [ __ ] over the counter
uh it's free over uh prescription though
oh yeah
don't and for the record don't
take an excessive amount of
medicine please take it baby don't
[ __ ] come on bro you trying to get me
kicked off youtube he was just playing
pretend yes pretend okay so open your
mouth show the camera there's nothing in
it yeah
see we don't we don't play with that
no there may come a day mike you come to
me asking for to be your best friend
there may be a time when this your
friend logan
when he's overstayed his welcome
there may come a time
[Music]
when you'll have to send a message
to our dear friend logan
we might have to
i'll tell you and this time
logan's not gonna be finding a dead body
in the forest
[Music]
he's gonna be the dead body
but you understand what i'm asking you
[Music]
i really hate to say this i think
there's someone hanging right there oh
my god
i haven't heard
yo that shit's so [ __ ] up i haven't
heard that in a minute bro
oh [ __ ] i didn't know you had that
queued up zack
[Music]
wow
[ __ ] wow to that sound bite
nah did mike i don't want to cut it you
know
yeah i think we'll have to keep pulling
obviously throughout the experience
maybe before and after the interview
that'd be kind of crushing though for
whoever lost i don't want to put them in
that position i want them to be
comfortable yeah i think we shouldn't
think of these polls that we've been
running as something definitive it's
more like election polling in the
lead-up to the election and then the
podcast is sort of like the debate night
right then i think after that we need to
have the official ballot election die
bold voting machines
mike lindell certified
the the works the whole shebang
yeah yeah yeah i think that i think
that's
hello by the way ab uh i found i i have
this new technology i pulled it straight
out of abe's dreams
yeah this is what he was dreaming of
last night
incredible stuff huh
that's a [ __ ] sim
wow that was close though shout out mike
you've got to be feeling good about that
showing we'll get him next year mikey
and jeff might be sweating a little bit
i'm not going to lie
[Applause]
could ethan give me a quick almost
unintelligible intelligible ninja style
shout out
shout out nicholas thanks for the 10
bucks buddy
that was perfect there you go
that was great
shout out nicholas thanks for the 10
bucks
[Music]
hey nicholas thanks for the ten dollars
buddy what did you say you didn't say
buddy says bro or
dude dude cameron grants
that's what the same box says nicholas
six four to ten
nicholas thanks for the 10 vape niche
bro
ellier
i mean if i want to make it as small as
possible nicholas thanks for the 10.
it's like hey nick thanks for watching
buddy
yeah there you go nicholas thinks about
tier one buddy
that was a jumper
wait are you in your ninja outfit
no nope
i think for two months oh what the hell
bro no ninja's in the office
[Music]
[Music]
nicholas thank you one
guys i'm not kidding by the way i want
to get more ninja shout outs too yeah
it's so good
thanks for two one nick
uh sam actually also just got a dm
uh just heard from g fuel so
oh let's [ __ ] go
huge w victory
royale a big day
[Music]
i've been promoting gpu i'm so happy
yeah
in the house
g field in the house let's get that game
refuel y'all
put it in your water and sip it down
g fuel in the house has small amounts of
lead but most things do
negligible amounts of lead
we don't joke about that
it does have negligible amounts of lead
based on
that somewhere i saw it somewhere
[Music]
it means it's fine wait wait i just
realized cut the music
before we get anything from g fuel did
did we remember to ask keem for
permission
[Laughter]
[ __ ] he does have the cotton candy
flavor yeah
yo we've got to get some of the cotton
candy flavor that says ninja on it
well that's the wolf yeah
keemstar screaming in silence that's my
best actually he's just in his room
this is like looking through the window
in this room and you can't hear but you
can just see
oh the pain so much pain
i'm so happy i have new friends though
life is so much better with friend with
good friends definitely
i'm happy for you
thanks bro
it's good for everybody yeah
uh moving on elon musk who i have
immoral and
immortalized
and the new shirt elon musk is a piece
of [ __ ] loser
uh
he basically so he's denying this is he
just lying is there any intel
there's a story that came out it's
pretty crazy
google co-founder
this guy sergey who was like worth 100
billion dollars she's a big deal
sergey and elon were best buddies
for a long time
and this a wall street journal very i
mean that's a reputable paper
right
i mean
[ __ ] the wall street journal honestly i
know but for right wing newspaper
however they wouldn't publish a story
like this if they weren't able to back
it up exactly about the richest man in
the world look their opinions are dog
[ __ ] but it's a reputable paper yeah
something like this it seems hard to
believe that they would just pull out of
thin air it's not it's not the daily
mail it's not the sun exactly newsweek
or some sort of tabloid you know so wall
street journal published an article
accusing elon musk of having an affair
with the co-worker of google's elon's
best friend sergey brin's wife
yo
he wants the type of dude to [ __ ] his
best friend's wife
that's what else do you need to say
about it
and then i mean obviously the wife like
what the [ __ ] wrong with you too but
the best friend that's the bro code
and the girl code we all know about the
girl and bro code it's your best friend
well elon claims that they're still good
this isn't true and there's a tweet of
them together just from a couple days
ago
show me that where's that in the docker
just from a couple days ago yeah
well that is actually interesting
if that's the case
let's see
elon musk gave this picture of himself
partying last night with sergey
we don't know
he
here we don't know the date
i mean that'd be kind of a dumb thing to
lie about
where i highlighted is his statement
you know these guys are worth
collectively like 300 billion dollars
you can have a plastic cup come on
save the ocean bro
haven't you done enough damage
what do they do out there when you're
worth 300 billion like what do you get
up to
[ __ ] each other's wives
apparently apparently the same [ __ ] all
the
everyone else is up to
yeah well
that sums it up
you know somebody said maybe they're
just swingers in the chat i mean
well
but well so the story alleges that
sergey who's one of his early investors
pulled out all of his investments and is
like on a spite mission now
right
so it's not like they're swingers it's
like he's
[ __ ] pissed
um i love how elon's like i'm so busy i
don't have any time for anything
dude has like nine kids
and in his free time he's hanging out
with his billionaire buddies bro you
have nine [ __ ] kids i love that
anyone's obsessed with repopulating the
world dude kids need their dads bro
somebody tell him kids need their dads
okay this is a feudal era medieval
[ __ ]
europe bro where people just grow up and
then die in a war at like 20 years old
we need well-adjusted people
we need to repopulate the earth with
well-adjusted people
not just people
please
we need dads
and moms but moms are obviously moms are
moms are solid they're always there
but okay this is this is pretty
compelling
this was us last afternoon
the problem here is that michael
from the wall street journal has zero
journalistic integrity
let's see if he's responded because he's
been called out by name
broken ties oh he has not responded
wow
that's [ __ ] interesting huh
i feel like if someone put out a story
about
like me and my friend and it was untrue
wouldn't you want to release statements
saying it's untrue sergey would say
something yeah not just like a creeper
shot with him in the background yeah
like don't you think both elon musk and
they could have been like shoulder and
shoulder flipping off the camera
oh it's not okay never mind like when
like when tati came back with her video
and she was like james wanted to be here
with me like it would have
more of james that's the vibe i'm
getting that's the vibe
i'm getting the vibe that tati is there
sans james
that's the vibe isn't it
you're gonna have to get better from
your buddy sergey to acquit you of this
[ __ ]
since the article uh uh was published
elon has denied it obviously he alleges
this is just an attempt to assassinate
his character which she
uh put out
uh right when he endorsed
ron desantis for president
um
interestingly now any any negative press
he gets is a conspiracy to assassinate
his character
uh in a statement elon says nicola
nicola and sergey's divorce has
absolutely nothing to do with me i'm
sure both nick
nicole and sergey would confirm that are
you are have they
i spoke with both sergey and nicole
about this and they said the story isn't
coming from them so it must be a case of
broken telephone two or three lawyers
removed why haven't they made a
statement
if you guys are best buds you should be
first out there
in it
what do we think
dude you can re don't repopulate the
earth with your best friend's wife dog
i don't know
what do we do about it what do we do
about this guys we're that story for
it's front page wall street journal yeah
wall street journal to put it out is
like an investigative piece look at this
this is like a huge piece for them
yeah it's just not even their mo to do
hit pieces so uh you know or just kind
of tabloid
rag
level stuff like this so i don't know it
even alleges that
at a recent party
which could have been that one that elon
musk was on his knees begging him to
forgive him
that's in this article right
ow yeah what are we going to do about it
what the hell are we going to do about
it
so did they post an update or something
we def i need to i need a follow-up from
wall street journal we're going to need
one they have not yet they have not uh
followed up
i bet they've heard from his lawyers
though
i would not want to be on the back end
of an elon musk lawsuit i'll tell you
that
the richest man in the world who just
tweeted by the way a few months ago i'm
looking for crazy ass lawyers to sue
anyone for any reason for me please
respond with cv
remember that [ __ ]
yep
love that
oh boy
this guy just looks so much like a
villain it's crazy
that hairline though
a little thin eh
just a little bit yup
sergey on the other hand
i mean look at that hairline that is
thick voluptuous beautiful i see what's
going on here
i see where the jealousy comes from
you know what i mean
yep
exactly
what do you think hmm [ __ ]
interesting stuff
well uh we eagerly await an update from
either of the involved parties
this is unlikely to be the end of this
story but i do agree that um
you know if it was total [ __ ]
them putting out a joint statement
saying that it's [ __ ] that would
have been over done immediately over
yeah done speculation done
which she could have easily done by now
especially if they were partying
together this weekend easily like he
wasn't even the one who posted the photo
of them together from this week elon
posted it and homie wasn't even paying
attention when the phone was taken
like he literally took a creeper shot
with him in the background also who's to
say that that was this week you know
well let's just assume it was
okay
like he's not even paying attention he's
talking to someone else
and there could be like hundreds of
people here and you just cruised over
there and took a photo
after begging on your knees for him to
forgive you
i'm sorry i wasn't paying attention
why it was a sound bite i know i'm
kidding
i've also never seen elon musk's face
look that way before this photo yeah
he's hiding the pain
he's like giving me a little too much
human you know mmm
he turned on the human chip
doing the soy face a little bit
now that is the total soy face
look at that this is an awesome soy face
bro
love that what's up guys i just [ __ ]
my best friend's wife
well we'll see man if sergey doesn't say
[ __ ] i think you're guilty because if it
didn't happen sergey would say so if you
[ __ ] around sergey is not saying [ __ ]
period
i think he did it
yup i think he [ __ ] this homie's wife
for the drama of it i also
think he did it it's good for my shirt
coming up too on thursday right yeah
prophetic
what else we got here guys
quartering selling whoa coffee uh
whatever i speed i show speed band we've
talked about this guy before
oh dude perfect sponsored video and
qatar is pretty awesome we need to talk
about speed because it's the title of
the episode today it's also pretty crazy
all right so this guy
i show speed we've talked about him
before
he's like probably one of the biggest
streamers right now yeah
for sure he's kind of a nutty dude speed
he'll i'll show you a picture you guys
probably recognize him i show speed
that's how i roll i have one speed i
have one gear go
[Laughter]
is that sheen
yes
so this is him you guys might recognize
him but i think he got banned off twitch
and then he moved to youtube what did he
get banned on twitch we have the clip in
there it was basically for threatening
to r-word a girl to her face
oh my god if you recall
oh he got banned for this clip okay
he got banned for this love you probably
know the lore
uh is it the one where he talks who's
gonna stop her on discord yeah he didn't
get bound for that whoa
this dude is off the [ __ ] rails
yeah so watch this
all right away all right look though i
got like a psychological question okay
say if we're the last two people on
earth by the way he's super young just
for the record how old is he he's like
17 or so 17 yeah so i mean
go easy on him he's 17 for christ's sake
but still he's pretty wild the world
continued would you all reproduce living
no because that means our kids will have
to intertwine and then they kill no
who gonna stop me
[Music]
oh
[ __ ] dude that's so that was the end of
his twitch career oh [ __ ]
it's like so crazy dude
i mean he's kidding right it's like a
bit yeah but
it's a lot
yeah it's a bit much
it's a lot
oh my god i think it's all part of the
andrew tate trend where it's like
dudes got so comfortable hating women is
crazy
oh man but okay that was wild as [ __ ]
he kind of blew up after the after he
got banned so that was kind of like a
disguised positive thing in getting
banned from twitch
you know i saw this clip it was super
viral but here's some of the comments so
this is interesting speed doesn't
realize 10 years from now these videos
are still going to haunt him that's
actually a really good insight yep
that clip is going to be hard to [ __ ]
live down dude
as far as you go and as popular as you
get
that clip is going to be on the internet
and that's what sucks about being 17 in
it it takes about being 25 i was saying
dumb [ __ ] not that dumb
everyone please don't ban speed twitch
who's going to stop me
imagine if you get catch a case and this
clip is played in the courtroom
speed is the main antagonist of his own
life actually you know i thought these
comments wouldn't be like based but
they're actually pretty uh
pretty on the nose
who's gonna stop me her i will that's
the right answer yeah so
it doesn't look like he could overpower
just for the record not that i ever
want that to happen but uh
not the stature
but anyway there that's to him and so he
moved over to
youtube where he how many viewers does
he get live on youtube he's quite 90k
90k this one clip that got him suspended
or banned that's pretty incredible
because
um gamers generally don't get a lot of
live views on youtube yet right love i
mean you even see the big guys like
ludwig came over and he get he doesn't
he averaged like 20k or something
yeah youtube is hard uh but i mean
the the gaming part is kind of just
background noise for his streams i guess
it's like the twitch culture i think
crossover
yeah i think as more and more people
come over obviously it'll be easier to
pull those numbers but
it's just the people are on twitch
but he pulls 90 and that's that's that's
really really a lot
so um
he was recently banned on youtube
or suspended right
it was down
he wasn't permanently banned was he no
he made it seem like he was yeah it was
only a two week man i believe
oh [ __ ] yeah he's dude he's about to hit
10 million
subs this is like he already hit it
yeah he hit it [ __ ] dude this guy's on
the rise
he's like leafyishere vibes just the
meteoric rise
[Music]
i i want to say he's not as bad somehow
olivia
yeah
dan
comment dan wants to say something
um
oh god he's in it bro
this is his channel
a one-piece stand
let's see his views
damn look at those views yeah this kid
is crazy bro
four million on his stream
with three
hour streams so yeah this guy's huge
guys i was laughing at how crazy it is
stop it was [ __ ] shocking and insane
that's why i'm laughing
it's crazy
so he did this uh last week
and uh he got a
bj fr in minecraft
yep which is really really a bad idea
legitimately in
minecraft exactly we're not figuring no
not the figurative not the way the world
is not the royal in minecraft years and
years ago
there used to be like a whole subgenre
of sexy minecraft videos they got a ton
of views and then youtube i guess caught
up with it and just outlawed it and
uh it became like super taboo because
it's a kids game especially i i don't
think i can show this i mean i can't he
got banned for it but we made a edit oh
you did oh that's great
let's go it's pretty crazy though
um
oh which one is it i don't see a clip in
here
um
[Music]
right here 2022 the clip that got him
banned
oh
i didn't know it was censored or like a
bridge yeah yeah this is there here we
go
but y'all y'all y'all can't see this
because you guys are too young and i
don't want to show this to young
children so i'm about to hide my screen
come on jenny baby
huh
what the [ __ ] even is this this is in
minecraft like a mod
they can i guess so yeah dude minecraft
is so wild
you guys caught all the weird [ __ ] out
right yeah we took out the audio as well
okay okay good
because it gets very graphic at a point
it does i've watched the clip so many
times i don't think
i know minecraft well you guys are
showing too much
you're showing too much
notch block yeah i got to block it but
you guys get where this is going it gets
into this whole graphic uh bj sequence
gosh yes
that's [ __ ] crazy dude
but there you have it um
another man
he's a boy let's be honest 17 but
another person responsible for the
downfall of uh
young young men everywhere
he's the trifecta aiden ross
i show speed andrew tate
is like the try
oh and fresh i don't think anyone cares
about fresh and fit they're like the
triforce of chauvinism of like
ruining young men
so um
peace out y'all
goodbye
you know
they gave me a strike
from the last stream the one stream
where uh i played the ginnymon and um
you know the thing popped up
and i know it was going to pop up so now
they gave me a strike man so
i'm going off youtube y'all so
peace out man i love y'all boys man
i'm sorry i'm
really waiting
he posted this after he got banned yeah
you can't do that
really
that
you can't post on any channel you own
after you get a ban
or they consider it a ban invasion yeah
so he could this could be [ __ ] does
that mean he gets a second strike
he apparently has one this was a second
if they're really gonna be hard ass on
him that that could be three
but i don't know i don't know if they do
that but technically like whenever i get
a strike my youtube rep calls and says
do not post on any channel you have
anywhere
you couldn't hear me together you know i
just want to do let y'all know i do love
you guys a lot man
but you know i'm gone okay whatever
bye
did you think he would get some kind of
uh backlash for the firework from
youtube
i guess yeah i thought he'd get a strike
for that that was like that was the
other clip we watched he had that
pikachu firework yeah oh in his room
inside and then the
fire department came to put it up i
thought that was a strike i mean that
was like super dangerous activity i
don't think he did get a strike for that
though yeah i was just reading some
articles out i didn't see anything about
a strike
dude i feel like i would have got a
strike for that [ __ ] easy every time
like joey [ __ ]
i don't know how we didn't get a strike
on this one
um no i don't think we should show this
whole can we pause it we've showed it no
i don't think we i don't think we did we
didn't show we didn't show it because it
got well you get the i guess you get the
idea and then and then if you go forward
the fire department's there
yeah this guy dude you listen dude
you're a talented dude people like you
you gotta chill dude you time to get
smart
you know also cool it on the rape jokes
yeah that's not good the chauvinism you
got to make a u-turn on all that [ __ ]
because that's not it uh gretchen said
speed was streaming at a water park
while i was there with my family and we
thought a bunch of kids were going to
drown
when he led the crowd into a pool oh
dude
wait i gotta see that
he's 17. it's [ __ ] up to give that
much influence to someone who's so like
unhinged 17 year old but
you need to figure it out now now or
never
i i have the video i'm just vetting it
first
look i'm saying talented like obviously
people like him he's entertaining it's
obviously not my cup of tea or anyone's
here i'm just saying i'm trying to give
the kid advice
he can probably be successful with all
of that without all the antics yeah
that's what i understand about like
people in his position or like j station
it's like you already have an audience
you don't have to keep doing this yeah
you don't have to right okay this is
wow his fans are young
dude how old is this kid like eight i
mean what the hell i'm serious this is
wow and like the stuff you're doing is
so bad influence on an eight-year-old
golly
well let's watch what happens
i can only imagine watching this there
this girl's like five years old what the
hell
and then someone's [ __ ] like
twerking
but what is happening
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah
this is what they do they do this they
tell someone they're going to be aware
and then they get there and record it to
like
make it cool look cool on stream
um
but
wow this dude needs a reality check bad
it seems like he was in the news every
week he leaked ksi's number the other
week oh [ __ ] yeah prior to that i think
he leaked something to do with ronaldo's
son
ronaldo's son yeah i think ronaldo son
watches him holy [ __ ] dude
yeah where is his parents it's a good
question this dude's 17 he's not even
like legally adult yet where are your
parents man
his dreams with his dad sometimes
is his what's his dad like i want to
meet that dad
it's kind of like tough i guess okay
okay interesting
[Music]
dude your fans are like five what the
hell
wow okay listen
it's interesting this you gotta you
gotta pay attention to stuff this is the
the new kid on the block
we gotta watch what's going on there but
yeah i hope you get smart that's it
somebody donated 50 dollars and said
apparently there's a war going on hassan
has taken the lead by an enormous margin
and has been officially voted the
hairline you're [ __ ] he's not have a
better hairline than me would it where
his son himself has said that he does
not have that it's obvious
nobody needs to say anything the man's
on hair support medicine
where's this vote tell me where the [ __ ]
i don't know this person donated 50 and
said you're losing a vote all right well
tell me where it is dude i don't know
because we'll rally the troops right now
yeah
it's just ridiculous i mean nobody's
going to believe that poll i don't care
how many people vote what a [ __ ] liar
dude no one can take that from you
listen i'm not saying i have the best
hairline in the world i've seen people
with better hairlines but not many
yeah mr [ __ ] is one keeping helping
hunk of a man
tucker on the other hand
well that's i show speed so everybody uh
get ready for the i show speed era
or maybe not depending on
what happens in the next week or two
yeah
just look at leafy bro you want to have
a long a longer career
just be smart
show the [ __ ] out
you know that's my advice
literally
literally
i get i mean oh yeah i want to talk
about dude perfect getting backlash for
doing a sponsored video for qatar can
you pull up human rights violations in
qatar dan
not that america is like a bastion of uh
i think we back qatar
well whatever we also back
saudi arabia everywhere yeah all the
shittiest
but um we have some guaranteed freedoms
in our soil even though they're
frequently trampled on by police and
stuff like that but
let's take a look at qatar before we get
into this dude perfect [ __ ] the sky uh
despite government reforms migrant
workers continue to face labor abuses
and struggled to
change jobs freely
curtailment of freedom of expression
increased in the run-up to fifa world
cup 2022 women and lgbti people continue
to face discrimination and law and
practice
yeah my favorite uh thing that
that happens frequently in these gulf
countries
is basically the enslavement
of migrant workers
uh water slaves
[ __ ] what is that
abuse and exploitation of migrant
workers preparing for
emirate preparing emirate for 2022
this article is more than eight years
old they've been working on it that long
yeah it's been like a very long term
project holy [ __ ]
just for some soccer
i mean yeah huge deal in that part of
the world
i mean everywhere it's the best
everywhere but yeah
well wait wait in the world what was
that story though what's what's a water
slave i don't even know what that is uh
i don't i don't know
oh it's not water slave it just says
yeah but anyway what they do is they
bring migrant workers over from like
poor
uh southeast asian countries
and basically take their passport
so they can never leave
and they force them into endangered
indentured servitude
uh and like abject poverty it's horrific
how many people died building the kurd
the burj khalifa or whatever like
until i mean they literally just well
that's in the uae
i know but they do the same thing with
the latest right yeah the slave uh 6 500
migrant workers have died in qatar
uh working on the world cup dude that's
crazy
a year ago
yeah so it's like
horrific i mean it ain't great
it's it's so bad
it's yes 6 500. how many and that's
that's just reported i'm sure yeah i
know so if they're like migrant workers
they get around that they don't have to
report it under certain dude yeah it's
got to be like five times more than that
yeah like when i look up uh the
uh khalifa right now it says four but i
know that they came four it says four
yeah so i'm gonna keep i'm digging
deeper
i thought it was like ten thousand is
what a number i heard
so anyway back to dude perfect um who
by the way dude perfect is like the
cleanest
family friend these are like the trick
shot guys i'm sure everyone knows who
dude perfect is right
so
here's their tweet
wait what it only has 300 likes how's
that possible
how come this suite only has 300 likes
wait their twitter
don't they have like 100 billion subs
on youtube they do i guess they're just
what they're doing
they seem to remember most of their
followers are kids and they probably
don't use twitter
that's kind of surprising wow it only
has 300 likes they probably paid them
like a billion dollars for that post
they got like one click
well they yeah they have 58 million
subscribers man
they're just like good old boys from
middle america
and uh anyway they say bucket list world
cup checked
all the boxes dune bashing world record
roller coaster a trip to all eight fifa
world cup stadiums
and more why do they need eight stadiums
isn't one enough
yeah i wasn't sure about that either
like
okay
thanks to qatar for letting us
experience all the country has to offer
uh the comments are like biggest mistake
ever willing to ignore the horrible
stuff happening qatar and stuff that is
happening surrounding uh qatar 2022
blatantly just enjoying the experience
literally over the lives of so many
workers that have passed because of the
tarot conditions i think that's a great
response and i'd like to see more people
saying that to people who go to like
dubai you know
yeah i'm reading that uh
fifa regulations require at least six
different stadiums to have a capacity of
at least 20 000.
um i'm guessing
homosexuality is illegal in qatar
the punishment is three years in prison
and a fine and possibility of death
penalty
that's awesome
that'll teach them
you won't be gay again after you go to
jail
there's also a lot of controversy around
the fact that qatar even got
the fifa i remember like i think it was
all like
weird back room dealings because it's in
like the summer it's gonna be like 110
degrees isn't that right dan that like
the whole qatar fifa connection is super
crooked
uh yeah i remember reading about it
it was because this has been going on
for so long uh you know i remember
reading about it years ago um
and yeah i think fifa had a big
corruption scandal related to it and
stuff but
a little hazy oh also um they need to do
matches at the same time that's why
there's so many stadiums
because of it oh okay okay complete the
cup that's crazy they built six stadiums
those those places are gonna be ghost
towns after the tournament's over
this ain't gonna age well yeah that
wasn't it in 2011
um
somebody a whistleblower claimed that
qatar paid uh one and a half million
dollars to the president of fifa that's
it that's all it cost uh
yes we just went to katana
that's a lot of money but you're talking
about
how much have they spent building the
world cup like billions of dollars for
sure
1.5 you got to butter the beak more than
that
here's their video simping for guitar by
the way guitar we raced camels f1 cars
went dude bashing rode the world's top
visited migrant slave camps
falls into a roller coaster and for the
first time ever visited all eight world
cup stadiums in one day this is bucket
list
[Music]
damn it's kind of crazy that like the
government of qatar
is reaching out to this like child
influencers
i'm sure that they paid them millions of
dollars for this
that's some crazy ass pr right there
all right we only have 48 hours so we
got to get to dune bastion pronto yeah
buddy it's my kind of day can you see
the like dislike on this
because
smart man
uh it's bad but it's not
horrific
um yeah 83 down that's pretty bad for
them
that's pretty bad
party time baby literally i'm surprised
so many people um
know about this stuff
kind of good to see to do this
finally here in qatar sand dunes are
calling my name
the sand dudes are calling my name
now we're on a camel
i'm this reminds me of like the tours of
north korea where they're like
everything is fine
don't look in the city
if you go off the approved circuit you
will be arrested put in hard labor
or do you think he enjoys it the whole
time
the first time in history you can see
all eight world cup stadiums in one day
we are here in
when i heard we're coming to qatar i had
to check out the f1 track
got a helmet a car and a track to go
fast welcome to stadium 97 i'm out of
group oh
can't let go of the turtle there you
have it i guess there's not much to it
just kind of wild
and that's about it
uh
there's the quartering selling coffee
who cares right is that a good story
should we talk about quartering well
e40 said no should we eat pizza for
dinner yep
oh are you gonna cry if she leaves
yep
are you gonna eat some cheese yup
you're gonna have some ice cream wait no
no
wait which one are we on
are we on a nope or yeah
you're gonna eat some ice cream no
you're gonna lose some weight yeah
no
no
are you reciting lyrics of the song are
you making this is freestyle bro okay
okay okay this is off the cuff man
let him do yeah this is all [ __ ] off
my dome
is
is mike my bestie
no
you got that wrong
hey man that take it up with e40 man
okay but i get confused which one are we
on now okay we're on we're on yep now
okay okay we're on yep is jeff my bestie
yep
am i chilling with michael no
me and tana cool yep
help me out guys
what are you afraid of ian
i'm trying to find something that rhymes
with you gonna eat tacos
do you like burritos no
do you elect a bachelorette
did you like the new episode no
i did actually did you watch it
it's good no
not you e40
do you watch the new nathan
yes i did yeah cliffhanger cliff super
big cliffhanger that [ __ ] like when i
was watching that
it's genius yeah it's insane genius i
don't know how it's even like
technically possible to do what they do
yeah bro
everybody got choices i'm stuck to this
money you're getting that bread
everybody got choices these [ __ ] just
hating they all in my head you got to
say it by the way the right way you
didn't say it at that time
everybody got choices ah i might uh 1000
i live in that life that i chose
got it
um i may or may not uh
be here on some of the uh subsequent
episodes what i i may have jury duty
this week
just tell them some bull crazy ass [ __ ]
when you get home we'll see what happens
what would you say they let me off the
hook today
just one day i have to check but i have
to check in again tonight and see if
they need me
what would you say
if you wanted what was the craziest
thing you could say straight up
to get excused from jury duty well this
is less uh so i hate the jews oh thank
you yup nope yep by
yup nope yup our saudi benefactor 50
gifted subs god bless you oh let's go
yeah so we love the gulf states now
don't we folks
yeah nope guitar
stan uh uae stanley mall yeah um
once they gave me money oh [ __ ] i love
saudi arabia
shut up mecca
but yeah i've heard that the though
you gotta start talking about jury
nullification and they'll uh they'll
kick you out of there real quick so i
might try and play wait wait wait what
is jury nullification that's when like
you that's when like you basically say
you you say somebody's not guilty even
though they're clearly guilty because
you think the law is unjust and there's
sort of like a that's like a common law
precedent that if that happens enough
time it can actually overturn the law
and uh judges do not
like that so what are you gonna say just
like yo i don't care what happened i'm
all about
uh because there are a lot of unjust
laws on the book and i cannot wait to
overcome just super biased you're going
to go in
you got to go in and say what rules you
sons of [ __ ]
up yours woke more or less judge who
says sit dan say you work in insurance
prominence that will work why would that
work
that's interesting what happens
they don't like insurance industry
people being on uh
death to all jews i mean you could just
honestly i like i'm such a like politics
and civics dork i i am kind of
curious to do it like i think it would
actually be kind of fun to just do it
once in your life to just have that
experience of what it's like to be a
dream yeah i agree but it's just so hard
but yeah i mean i i can't i mean look
you get stuck on the o.j simpson case
you got to disappear for like a year bro
i mean obviously that's very unlikely
it's probably just some [ __ ]
but but uh trials take a long
says just say you're a sovereign citizen
yeah they probably oh that's a good one
sovereign citizen
i mean you could just say
uh
you know i don't like minorities in
general
that's what everybody jokingly says i i
do not have it in me too even you could
be really polite about it like listen i
uh
i just want to say
that i have nothing against them
theoretically on an individual basis but
as far as minorities goes
not a big fan
something like that somebody's going to
clip that
he's in love
with peace and love of course
dan say you only speak spanish i doubt
that's an issue here in los angeles
there's probably some ways of dealing
with that
just be true to yourself and say all
cops are bastards say tell me your
pathological liar you have a um
personality disorder you're a
parathyological liar
that would be dude that would be a
killshot
why i have hysteronic personality
disorder hey
work with me
bingo
this guy's too annoying to be a juror
get him the [ __ ] out of here
i mean you could just say i'm and i am
incapable of being impartial i cannot be
done
it just cannot be done i'll tell you
what he's guilty i already know it i'm
voting guilty
i'll just tell you no matter what you'd
be like no matter what you present to me
he's guilty
i hate criminals they're all guilty
i can't jerk off to this
i couldn't jerk off to this could be a
good one
[Music]
say you know the guy on the trial you
just lie you say you know him
that's my buddy
hey what's up you don't even know what
the case is yeah yeah
but we'll see i might just not even get
called in that's what happened today i
wasn't sure if i was gonna be here for
today's show but they said nope
nope nope
do you have to report to the jury nope
but are you on call tomorrow yeah yep
you gonna get called in tomorrow no we
gonna do a show yep
will i be everybody got choices
will abe be able to cover me no oh no is
the show gonna do well without dan yeah
oh that was i don't know
right
hey
dan's about to serve on a jury just tell
them that you're blind that doesn't
matter tell them that you're mute you're
helen keller can't see [ __ ] impartial
can't even think about it
though
yeah that's what helen keller's thing
can't think can't see well how is she
going to take in the information
i've wondered that too she wrote a book
apparently
i don't buy it i don't buy it either i
think the whole helen kellen thing is is
it's a hoax
she wrote a book she's blind and deaf
yeah what she got to write about dude
don't you know the whole story
well she's got this
braille yeah how can you convey that
i watched a movie in high school didn't
explain it well
yeah it was uh it was like an apple was
the breakthrough moment can i ask you to
remember seeing that movie i i i
remember seeing that movie i didn't see
it in school but my parents don't know
we scanned helen keller and then
she was real but it's tough yeah
was she born blind and uh deaf no yeah
yeah no
i thought she was if she was blind and
deaf from birth there's no [ __ ] way
that she's from birth i'm pretty hell in
colorism when did she lose her
let me see
i actually made a rock opera about it
it's called tommy
uh
a miracle worker thank you somebody in
the chat
that's the movie that i'm talking about
when did she lose her her sight and
hearing this is infancy yeah
no no no dude she was born without sight
or hearing right yeah uh incredible but
i don't get it no she was at 19 months
uh she got an illness scarlet feet
possibly scarlet fever possibly they
don't know for sure
people are saying somebody say wasn't
she an ableist you're asking if helen
keller
[Laughter]
i don't know that's funny about that one
this is an ableism super racist they're
saying i'm being ableist
no no that well maybe they're saying
that too but people are saying how is
she racist
how does she know i don't know all of
that
yo type helen keller racism i got to
know that story
was she virgin by the way i'm just
curious about that i don't know can you
consent well i guess you could talk she
learned a dog
through sign she learned to sign
and do braille and all that how did she
communicate did she
like verbally
well she wrote i guess i gotta watch
that movie but
i'm just saying i guess it's more
incredible if it's true at the beginning
of the i'm just kidding i believe this
story i'm just saying absolutely at the
beginning of the pandemic it was like a
meme on tick tock that helen keller was
fake or like oh it was the story of it
was well it is kind of unbelievable i
mean yeah it's a funny it's a funny meme
because she's so incredible that it's
like there's no way i'm singing letters
to the naacp where she supports their
efforts
how did she do that i'm feeling very
her teacher taught her skeptical of um
of miss keller
1900s the socialist party was
one of the only political groups in the
country that was pushing for civil
rights for black people and stuff so it
does seem like a stretch that uh i got
to educate myself on that we got a
keller thing saturday miracle worker
stream reaction stream
yeah the only thing you know if youtube
removes that they're definitely ableist
uh david jones says have you kept
on some of the reporting richard lewis
has done recently on cs go the biggest
she was a eugenicist and believed
disabled babies should be left to die
how how
yeah
that's that's literally hurt
she wrote a book about eugenics i mean i
there's a lot of accusations being
thrown out right now i don't know what
is it helen keller is getting drafted
told me delete it fat that's what i just
read
yeah we're learning a lot a lot is
coming about about helen keller i just
want you guys to know
do you think her ghost is deaf and blind
i don't know because if she she probably
can't even hear us there are a lot of
people who
who are blind or deaf that are asked if
they would
i think it's normally blind people are
asked like you had a complicated
relationship with disability like
radicals and conservatives of her time
she fully supported the policies of
eugenics and euthanasia movements
arguing that disabled children's lives
should not be sustained
wow
feels a little wait so they're saying
she is an ableist so they weren't
yelling at me maybe that is i mean
ableist if you're saying disabled people
shouldn't be born helen keller actually
one of stalin's political advisors she
says don't [ __ ] yeah let's get the [ __ ]
out of here
uh she was a
what the [ __ ] yo can you pull up some of
her readings about eugenics
let's get on that helen keller [ __ ]
yo that woman learned to breed
in the pit of nothingness just so she
could [ __ ] on other
disabled people those seem a little
a little absurd does it not
someone's
the first source that popped up is the
federalist i am not believing anything
on that someone just wrote in the chat
someone said she was a lip reader she
was blind
she ain't bringing no lips we're being
trolled and i'm sure some of it is real
but there there's don't believe
everything in the chat right now there's
a lot of uh no
could helen keller see
nope could she read lips though
did she stand for eugenics of all
disabled people
no
oh
he farted says no
he would know we do a little trolling
it's called we do a little trolling it
says her dabbling uh someone said denver
her dabbling in eugenics was brief
it didn't last and she changed her mind
she could read lips by touching faces
oh okay i hope she'll wash her hands
good
get her hands open my mouth
and then what the next person
don't want helen keller around during
covet
yo for real
just saying
uh jess says helen keller killed my
entire family so damn
that's rude
ellen keller did 9 11.
but it was a mistake
well she she was trying to fly the plane
but that's the joke yeah but it was a
mistake she couldn't see and then
everyone was like help she's like
official narrative everyone was yelling
the runway's over there
she couldn't hear that either
she said no i read its lips it's over
here they're like no no not the building
the airport's over here
but she ran it it was the building she
would float because she couldn't hear
them another happy landing
there was a really solid radio lab
episode that came out in response to
that tick tock trend the miracle worker
isn't a great portrayal according to
historians thank you sarah
helen keller supported nft's vo stick
says
[Music]
so there you have it
helen keller ladies and gentlemen
from a burning car
is that right
that right
thoughts
i wear these glasses in her honor
that's good wait someone says she was
the co-founder of the aclu
is that true
what did she sign the passage on the
paperwork
did you put her name on that [ __ ] i
don't know nope yeah that is correct
yeah she's the co-founder of the aclu
okay go off queen
that's crazy
that's incredible she's kind of
incredible inchi
[ __ ] legend yeah like unbelievably
incredible
there's a lot of interesting information
coming out about her in chat
all right i gotta go
she's [ __ ] dead who cares
i'm just kidding
just kidding guys come on you know you
know we love helen keller here
we love everything she's accomplished
world war one i'm actually saying that
she's still alive so you're good
hell no let's get her on the pod
oh my god
my theory is once they're dead we forget
we move on we move on
uh apparently i cut off olivia at some
point everybody's spamming it sorry
about that olivia um that's okay i don't
remember i don't remember that happening
either i i remember oh okay i think
you're about to say a lot of people ask
blind people if they have dreams
no i do remember what i was saying a lot
of people
uh a lot of blind people when asked if
they would like to be given sight if
given the opportunity they say no oh
what which is interesting because helen
keller said that she said they're liars
too
but helen keller that disabled baby is
that true pull that up then fact check
that
i find it interesting if it is i've
heard that too but i i think it's true
actually yeah i've heard you do you want
it there's a there's a blind youtuber
named molly
um
i don't remember her last year
oh i know molly oh shut up
she got that sixth sense like daredevil
probably
she's a slay
she hears those clicks
molly let me find her last name
shout out to all of our blind and deaf
kings and queens out there molly burke
molly burke oh what a legend oh yeah we
know molly burke yeah she's great
yeah
um
you know and uh
i'm all for like accessibility ramps
you know
you know what i'm saying absolutely we
need handicapped spots sometimes there's
too many i'll be honest
but like they need to be there i won't
disagree yeah sometimes there's like 10
and all the rest of the parking lots
full and like there's 10 empty handicap
spots i'm just saying maybe we're too
generous with the handicap
we could cut back a few spots but we
love them nonetheless right dan
people that need handicap
no no i'm pro handicap spot i'm just
saying some locations have maybe a cup a
couple too many i think we have the
right amount of handicap spots
we can't touch that i'm not
i'm not going down this route okay so
you can't drag me down okay all right so
i'm rolling that one back so we need we
need the right amount of handicap spots
we need them all it's rewind i'm being
told we need all the handicapped spots
correct
in sweden it's super easy to get the
handicapped plaque
oh really i have a friend with or i mean
maybe some if you have adhd
you could get a handicap spot what are
you going to get you're going to get
distracted on your way to the building
somebody's thinking it's that bad i
guess i there's probably a good reason
for for her to have that but
yeah i'm just saying if you have adhd
you can get it in sweden
wow
texas is easy to get here too zach do
you think i could get one for having
tourette's
yeah probably that's [ __ ] crazy bro
maybe i should one for tourette's no
zack says i can dan don't listen to zach
he's wrong
i'm reading in the chat even helen
keller didn't qualify for disability
parking
so that is actually the bar's quite high
yeah you know what guys um
yeah so
anyway we love our disabled folks we
love them you guys are all heroes
no eugenics [ __ ] that [ __ ]
right dan
yeah i'll back you up on that one yeah
no no eugenics yep
this is a no eugenics podcast okay okay
cool
thank you very much
all right it's all jokes guys i'm just
having fun we love them all guys listen
oh but yeah actually yeah so this was
actually really tragic um
they were all telling her no no no no no
go the other way
the airport is that way i'm pretty sure
she actually did fly a plane at one
point hell no no i'm not kidding
god that's incredible man she did it all
right
please
in 1946 keller and she fought a bear
traveled to europe to speak on behalf of
the american foundation of overseas
blind it was during this flight that
keller took control of the plane
interviews with the pilot and crew
reveal an incredibly confident woman
flying a plane steadily
and
calmly man this is awesome paul bunyan
[ __ ] everyone's just writing stories
about her yeah i mean all right but no
she's amazing but anyway look listen
it's really tragic what happened here
um i don't know who let her fly that
plane
but clearly the airport was that way she
just couldn't see
yep
ah this horrible tragedy
cam made this by the way don't blame me
who inspired it though come on
we're in this together
love do you even know who helen keller
is is that somebody that's taught no
i just know
[Music]
[Laughter]
she hated disabled people uh oh [ __ ]
catherine donated 20. she said this is
teetering on jimmy lee levels yeah you
might be right
maybe it might be time to back it up
i don't know about that it's fine it's
also fairly old jimmy lee would go up to
a deaf person be like hey can you hear
me hey bozo
your mother it's okay she can't hear me
exactly you can't see well i got my eye
on you he would trip a blind person no
he you know what you tell helen keller
would say
you can't hear or see but the worst part
is you're ugly that's a good thing
because if you saw yourself you'd have
you'd die of a heart attack who let you
out of your titties huh
that's what he always says yeah dude
that's so [ __ ] up
stink joint she co-founded it
should we have jimmy do a set on helen
keller
oh my god because like who's going to be
offended at the end of the day except
every distinctive person and other
people literally everybody yeah 100 of
everyone
oh [ __ ]
who let the air out of your titties that
is so obscene that is so disgusting and
rude that's uh dr james wine the jimmy
classic
bingo
how do you i can't even place what time
period that joke would come from i mean
like 1950s yeah maybe i can't even
imagine all right
like
you can't see like i think it was
probably even rude then to be honest
hey watch your step there you're gonna
watch your step you blind [ __ ]
island car was cracked at fortnight
that i'd believe
she was cracking 90s dude
oh yeah
oh yeah yeah
all right guys
having too much fun
everyone be good
love y'all
fun show today
wednesday someone says i'm definitely
haunted by helen keller's ghost now
what's she going to say what's she going
to do
how's she going to find the right house
she'll find a way
she's persistent
she's just a lot of things in her life
oh my god that one's actually true helen
keller
and keller got order 666
[Laughter]
she got confused for a robot or jedi the
jedi
the robots were the baddies
general grievous do we have anything fun
fun for wednesday to tease
um uh what's going on this wednesday did
you ever get a hold of the doctor my
doctor bro down
the diet coke
i emailed him he hasn't answered yet are
you sure he did me on instagram actually
friday thursday because he keeps
messaging me like you haven't heard from
your people
tell them to look out for for my email
okay
i sent it
it was like last
tuesday
yeah it's been it's been a minute
okay i just i just poked him because i
want to talk to him
um
do we have we don't have anything
interesting on wednesday i thought we
did nope any games or stuff i guess
we're working on just kidding
well you didn't send him an email no he
i got a response okay good so let's get
him on wednesday beautiful
doctor aids
what
i was wondering if it was doctor aids
that was yes that's my boy yeah that's
my boy yeah he's interesting i love his
[ __ ]
all right well anyway we'll see on
wednesday guys
thank you thank you with peace and love
this is a serious message
no more hating on helen calder thank you
thank you with peace and love socialist
queen
no
more helen kander slander anymore
helen keller slander you're gonna be
banned i'm warning you with peace and
love
we have too much love to share
thank you thank you
peace and love peace and love
[Music]
you